Guten Abend.
Hallo. Wir beide sind's, ihr kennt uns. Das ist Wolfgang und ihr habt es gemerkt im Hintergrund, Attraktion in Nebel. Ich weiß auch nicht warum, Wolfgang hat es bestellt. Ist heute der große Frisuren-Reveal?
Nein, heute noch nicht.
Warum ist so laut? Stört euch dieser Show-Effekt?
Na, es zieht glaube ich ganz gut ab, der Nebel.
Aber es ist schon wieder aus.
Es ist glaube ich das größte Problem, dass es hier sehr schwül ist, aber wir werden die Gemüter, so viel sei versprochen, noch weiter erhitzen. Frisurenreville kommt irgendwann später, aber es scheint alles... Es scheint alles gut zu funktionieren und es war ja so, als es sich machen ließ, war dann die Maßgabe vom Arzt, Herr Schmitt, zwei Wochen kein Alkohol, keine Zigaretten, kein Sex. Jetzt fragst du dich natürlich, was ist dir am schwersten gefallen? Und ich sage es dir, es war die Zigarette danach, ja.
So kennen wir ihn, unseren Wolfgang. Gut, wer von euch hatte denn die Freude, uns schon gestern intimer kennenzulernen? Ist jemand hier, der aus der Oper? Hände gehen hoch, Hände gehen hoch. Ah ja, hier, genau. Gut, also wir waren gestern in der Oper und es hatte sich herausgestellt, es sind einige unsern, wir haben ja nicht eingeladen, sondern wir haben gesagt, wir sind da. Einige sind diesem Angebot gefolgt, waren mit uns in La Jouif. Und wir haben dann gefragt, wo kommt ihr her? Und dann hieß es Freiburg, München, Dresden. Daher die Frage, ich weiß, es sind Frankfurter hier, aber wer kommt nicht aus Frankfurt?
Also die überwiegende Mehrheit kommt nicht aus Frankfurt.
Wer von euch glaubt denn, dass er die weiteste Anreise hatte? Ruft mal rein. Zürich. Kann das jemand überbieten? Wien. Das war übrigens Konstanze. Habt ihr mal eine Stimme gehört? Okay, wir sind ein internationales Publikum. Wir müssen euch also erklären, wo ihr hier seid. Also ihr seid in Frankfurt am Main. Ihr seht hier das ehemalige und das aktuelle größte Gebäude Deutschlands. Kleiner Fun-Fact zu dem, ich hab's schon ein paar mal genannt, ihr seht das mal rechts von der Commerzbank-Zentrale steht jetzt der T1 von Four Frankfurt, also so muss man das hier nennen, und wurde für 1,4 Milliarden verkauft, das erste Gebäude für über eine Milliarde Euro, drei Wochen vom Ukrainekrieg. Und wir kennen alle Turbulenzen danach. Außerdem in Frankfurt die größte Fan-Meile Deutschlands und der größte Fußballfernseher Deutschlands. Und für alle, die gestern in der Oper dabei waren oder demnächst mal in die Oper wollen, die größte Drehbühne Deutschlands und sogar Europas, damit auch das größte Drama, das möglich ist auf dieser Bühne.
Du musst noch sagen, was kostet diese Fan-Meile?
Ja, also diese Fan-Meile kostet 15 Millionen Euro und hat einen Bestand von vier Wochen. Plus Minus Stress, Aufbau, Abbau, das ist hier der größte Fernseher. Es gibt noch acht weitere Leinwände, also man kann auf 1,34 Kilometern sich das da anschauen. Es passen über 30.000 Leute drauf. Ich dachte auch zuerst, das ist übertrieben. Dann war ich aber gestern da, als ich festgestellt hab, ach so, manchmal finden ja auch noch Spiele in Frankfurt statt. Also gestern fand ich ein sehr großes, wichtiges Spiel statt. Wir kommen gleich drauf zu sprechen. Ich war, die Fanmeile zieht sich bis zur Oper. Ich war an der Oper, aber mit einem siebenjährigen Sohn, von dem ich wusste, der muss noch mal nach Hause und ich muss wieder zurück zur Oper. Während mit mir 30.000 Dänen und 30.000 Engländer sagten, ich muss auch in diese Richtung. Also es war sehr stressig gestern.
Und dann hat Stefan mich angerufen und das passiert so gut wie nie. Und ich dachte, was ist los? Und er wollte mich vorwarnen, dass ich doch bitte irgendwo in Frankfurt-Ost-Parke auf keinen Fall zur Oper hinfahre. Was hab ich gemacht? Ich bin natürlich ein deutscher Autofahrer und sage, ich fahre da jetzt mal rein. Und das hat fast zu einem Fiasco geführt, zumindest zu vielen Tobsuchsanfällen, dann hinterm Steuer. Und ich habe dann nachher mein Auto so abgestellt, dass es so einigermaßen ging, und hab es pünktlich geschafft. Aber die Liebe zum Fußball ist jetzt bei mir nicht gestiegen, vor allem auch zu den Fußballguckenden. Also ich habe wirklich gedacht, als ich es gestern sah, im Grunde ist es auch ein Rückfall in die Barbarei.
Ja, also gerade gestern.
Du merkst Verhalten und Applaus.
Ja, ich teile das auch nicht. Also es ist natürlich kein Rückfall in die Barbarei. Trotzdem wollen wir kurz am Drama-Maßstab kleben bleiben. Also das ist die größte Drehbühne der Welt, was bedeutet, wenn man dieses Foto leicht aus anderer Perspektive macht, sieht man, wie klein eigentlich der Zuschauer-Saal ist im Vergleich zu dieser 38 Meter weiten Bühne, die sich da hinten drehen kann. Was bedeutet, und ich war ja gestern auch zum 23. Mal in der Oper, man kommt in dieses Gebäude und hat Bühnenrealität. Ist das eigentlich ein Grundbegriff? Bühnenrealität?
Vielleicht, ja. Das ist auch noch mal bei der Theaterwissenschaft nachfragen.
Ist eigentlich immer sehr viel los. Gestern allerdings, man kommt in die Oper, das ist der Eingang der Oper. Um 15 Uhr, ich dachte mir, da ist doch eine 3-Stunden-Vorstellung, zu der ich hin will, kommt man da durch, stelle sich dann raus, die sind alle 10 Meter nach vorne gefahren und man konnte dann rein.
Also ein Polizeiaufgebot, wie ich das selten mal gesehen habe.
Ja, wir machen jetzt den Kontrast. Wir sehen hier die Regisseurin von gestern, die erzählt mal kurz, was gestern in der Bühnenrealität stattfand.
Das Ganze spielt zur Zeit des Constanze Conciles. Also 1414, die katholische Kirche ist komplett gespalten. Es gibt zu diesem Zeitpunkt drei Päpste. Und das kann natürlich auf Dauer so nicht sein. Denn alle Gelder, die in die Kirche gehen, landen nicht mehr in einem Topf, sondern in drei Töpfen. Alle streiten sich darum, wer jetzt der wahre Papst ist. Und schließlich kommt Kaiser Siegesmund auf die grandiose Idee, wir müssen uns alle versammeln zu einem Konzil und das einmal klären. Und was passiert ist, dass sich in diesen vier Jahren, 1414 bis 1418, also wirklich die halbe Welt in dieser kleinen Stadt Frankfurt versammelt.
Kleiner Fake am Ende, die kleine Stadt Frankfurt, große Versammlung. Also drei Päpste, ein Kaiser, vier Stunden Oper, da ist ganz schön was los. So, dann hört diese Oper auf, wir verlassen die Oper und sehen das. Und denken, oh, das ist aber viel Polizei. Was ist denn hier los?
Und Wasserwerfer auch noch.
Wir gehen einen Schritt weiter, oh, zwei Wasserwerfer. Und was ihr kaum seht, dazwischen steht noch so ein grüner, ich schieb mal alles aus dem Weg, Panzer. Mit so einem Schneeschaufel, aber es ist in dem Falle eine Menschenschaufel. Ja, ist jedenfalls einiges los. Und es stellt sich raus, völlig zurecht. Denn gestern wirklich ganz großes Drama, es fand quasi ein Konzil statt. Allerdings nicht in der Oper, es hat nur bis zu uns Auswirkungen gehabt. Also ihr seht hier den kleinen Opernvorplatz. Und wir verlassen ihn, denn es ist ja Europameisterschaft. Ihr seht hier den schönen Main und nicht weit Stadion. Im Stadion gestern, diese beiden Typen. Wie heißen sie? Wer weiß es? Wie heißt der rechts im Bild? Also irgendwer hat Friederik genuschelt, das ist zu zehn Prozent richtig. Also ich habe euch mal die kompletten Namen inklusive Titel eingeblendet. Wir lesen sie nicht alle vor, also links kennt ihr ja soweit, das ist uns Thomas. Mit ihm haben wir ja schon viel über das britische Königshaus gesprochen, aber es war auch Friederik, André, Hendrik, Christian von Schleswig-Holstein, Sonderburg, Luxburg, König von Dänemark und Graf von Mont-Pasier, Pisa hier.
Also der dänische König.
Der dänische König und wahrscheinlich wollte der Britte mal wissen, was faule ist.
Aber der britische König kam nicht, sondern hat nur den Sohn, also den guten Sohn geschickt. Der andere, haben wir ja alles im Salon schon verhandelt, kann jetzt gerade nicht die Royals vertreten.
Also wir haben hier, ja ja, es fand schon mal vor 600 Jahren Konzert statt und vor 200 Jahren wurde ein Oper gemacht, aber gestern, gestern war hier zu Recht Stress in der Stadt. Das ist das große Drama gestern. Also Oper in Frankfurt, wenn wir das nächste Mal sagen, wir gehen in die Oper, stellt euch auf Halligalli ein. Wolfgang führt uns in ein schwieriges Thema.
Ein schwieriges Thema, weil es mir ein bisschen unangenehm ist. Fast alle, die hier sind, kennen vermutlich Albrecht von Lucke, der Herausgeber der Blätter, der gern gesehene Interviewgast in ganz vielen Formaten, der Mann, der viele Vorträge hält und den man so zum progressiven linken Lager irgendwie zählen würde. Jedenfalls würde man ihn keineswegs bei den Konservativen oder den Rechten einordnen. Albrecht von Lucke war nun bei Jenny Günther im Einmischen-Podcast zu Gast. Vier und halb Stunden haben sie miteinander diskutiert und die ersten vier Stunden auch unkontrovers. Dann aber ging es um die Frage Werbpflicht, Dienstpflicht, was wäre denn eigentlich zu leisten? Ich gebe das jetzt mal ganz kurz wieder. Jenny leitet das Ganze so ein, dass sie fragt, ob das denn nicht eine zu große Anspruchshaltung des Staates sei. Die jungen Leute sind bei Corona vergessen worden. Die jungen Leute finden keine Wohnungen. Also eine ähnliche Argumentation, die wir sie wohl auch machen würden. Und jetzt kommt der Staat und sagt, jetzt tu mal was für dein Land. Und diese Frage stellt sie in meiner großen Offenheit. Und wir hören uns jetzt mal den ersten Teil der Reaktion an.
Weil natürlich meine Auffassung diametral entgegengesetzt ist. Ich verstehe es auch gar nicht. Ich kann nicht ehrlich sagen, ich bin völlig sprachlos. Es ist ja ein Generationendiskurs, den wir jetzt führen offensichtlich. Wobei es richtig lustig ist, dass du als Staatsdienerin jetzt anders agierst, als ich, der ich nie im Staatsdienst war. Das ist auch lustig, aber das macht ja nichts.
Ich empfinde, dass der Staat unter Angriff steht. Und das ist ja, finde ich, als Staatsdiener ein Problem.
Du artikulierst ja den Angriff. Du machst doch diejenigen stark. Und das ist doch die Paradoxie. Ich wäre derjenige, der jetzt all das, was du formulierst, absolut negieren würde, in jeder Hinsicht. Ich nehme diese junge Generation als eine zum Teil, die mal ganz hart sogar wohlstandsverwahrloste Generation war. Ja, ich mache das mal ganz hart. Kommt mir ja mal gespannt, was für Reaktionen kommen. Ich sag's mal. Wo soll irgendwie eine Verpflichtung dieser jungen Generation existieren? Konsum orientiert bis dort hinaus? In ihrer Freiheitlichkeit?
So, wer fühlt sich angesprochen? Niemand?
So langsam erhitzen sich die Gemüter. Wir hören mal weiter und kennen auch diese Argumentation zum Beispiel von einem CDU-Politiker wie Thomas de Maizière. Dann geht doch mal in die Parteien.
Sie hängt von Anfang an an ihren Handys. Sie ist nur privatistisch. Sie ist noch nicht mal in Parteien. Sie ist nicht in Vereinen. Die ganzen Organisationen der Gesellschaftlichkeit verlieren an Mitgliedern. Wo ist die in Anspruchnahme? Du artikulierst die ganze Zeit nur Ansprüche gegenüber einem Staat, der er sichtlich große Probleme hat, völlig recht. Durchaus auch wegen einer... Da müssen halt die Jungen, sag ich übrigens jedes Mal, dann geht in Parteien, verdammt euch nochmal. Kümmert euch um eure Interessen, jammert doch nicht. Du hast doch keinen jugendlichen... Du artikulierst eine... Ich bin da auch erreichlich verblüfft. Du bist doch selbst tätig. Du hast doch keine Veranlassung, eine Jugend in Schutz zu nehmen, die eine permanente Anspruchshaltung äußert. Es gibt in diesem Land BAföG, es gibt vieles, wo alle unterstützt werden.
Wer fühlt er sich von BAföG unterstützt? Damals, vor 20 Jahren, als die Mieten noch 20% gekostet haben.
Da er es so sehr atominem macht, also im Sinne von, du willst das ja gar nicht hören, dass ich das sage, aber insofern, dass er die da so persönlich angreift, würde ich dann noch sagen, na ja, Albrecht von Lucke ist Sohn eines Kaufmanns und einer Ärztin, der hat wahrscheinlich keinen BAföG beintragen müssen. Und wenn dann zu Zeiten, als das tatsächlich noch alles ein bisschen besser lief. Und es ist ja doch sehr erstaunlich, dass das also diese Talking Points sind, die wir eigentlich aus dem konservativen Lager, aus den Fokuskolumnen kennen, die aber jetzt hier von progressiver Seite vorgetragen werden und überhaupt keine Reflexion darüber an den Tag gelegt wird, wie die Situation eigentlich ist.
Es ist vor allem in dieser Ansprache, er meint uns ja alle. Und zwar alle rein geburtsjahre höher als 79 oder so, zack, alle sind gemeint. Und das finde ich wirklich wahnsinnig interessant, denn Albrecht von Lucke, ich habe ja auch schon mit ihm diskutiert auf der Bühne, da hat er ja gesagt, ich bin Jahrgang 64 und von dem wissen wir ja 1,4 Millionen Geburten. Also wirklich viel, doppelt so viel wie die aktuellen. Und man könnte ja diesen Vorwurf genauso pauschal zurückgeben. Christian Stöcker hat dieses Buch geschrieben, Männer, die die Welt verbrennen. Und dann das mal gemünzt auf, ja, Jahrgang 64, also dann bist du einer der Männer, die die Welt verbrennen. Wir haben gehört in Indien für eine Milliarde Menschen 51 Grad und zwar über mehrere Tage, wenn nicht sogar Wochen in Süden Pakistans. Diese Zahl, ich hätte heute Morgen fast noch einen Clip gemacht, aber ich dachte mir, nee, den hebe ich mir für nächste Woche auf. Wir wollen ja nicht die Stimmung so versterben, aber dieses Pilgarngrade in Mecca und dann findet eine Berichterstattung statt, in der nach einer Minute, so drei Sekunden vor Schluss, noch mal die Zahl genannt wird, dass da 1000 Menschen wegen Hitze gestorben sind. Also mittlerweile sind diese Zahlen gar nicht Anlass für Berichterstattung, sondern nur noch so Illustrationen-Kulisse eines, ja eigentlich sollten wir dann mal, und deswegen wir hören den Clip dann, brauchen wir jetzt nicht mehr Anpassungsleistung und so weiter. Also das Verhindern wird dann nur noch so in den allerletzten 0,3 Sekunden als Wissenschaftler-Versuchen noch zu verhindern, aber findet eigentlich gar nicht mehr statt. Also wir sind jetzt im Anpassungsmodus und stellen irgendwie fest, Anpassung klappt eigentlich nicht und wer hat es verbockt? Naja, dieselben quasi.
Wenn man jetzt diese doch sehr simple Generationen-Aufwiegelung machen will, die ihr hier betreibt, das ist so eigenartig, wir hören mal weiter.
Nur mal ganz konkretes Beispiel. Seit 30 Jahren mache ich fast, seit 25 Jahren mache ich diesen Job. Und ich gehe hier jedes Mal, früher war ich hier noch mehr in der Relation, ich gehe dann raus und gehe in eine öffentliche Landschaft, wo die Kneipen besetzt sind von Jugendlichen jedes Alters. Und willst du mir hier weismachen, dass das ganze jugendliche Volk, ich sage mal ganz polemisch, aber das meine ich aus tiefsten Herzen, die sich nur verlustieren, die abends Halligalli machen, die übrigens am Ukrainekrieg kein bisschen Anteil genommen haben? Hast du den Eindruck, dass hier irgendwie große Debatten über den Ukrainekrieg stattfinden? Hast du den Eindruck, dass damals bei Fridays for Future war das eine Aufstand? Ich sehe nichts in dem Punkt, was die junge Generation macht. Ich sehe noch nicht mal die Fragestellung, die heute diskutieren. Das finde ich auch eine reelle Diskussion. Die fragen sich durchaus, was würde ich eigentlich machen? Das ist ja auch eine…
Ja, und da ist jetzt die letzten drei Sekunden weg. Sie fragen sich also, wo sie hingehen könnten. Und da würde ich sagen, es ist ja genau die richtige Frage, die man sich stellt, was wäre Krieg, wo könnte man also hin? Und das ist für ihn vollkommen unverständlich.
Wir müssen auch kurz markieren, diese Floskel. Wir sagen es polemisch, meinen es aber von Herzen. Die müssen wir ab sofort immer unterbringen. Wenn wir wieder im Presseklub sitzen, bei Lanz oder wo auch immer, dann muss diese Floskel fallen.
Ja, sehr richtig. Und es ist ja auch sehr bemerkenswert, dass er also hier so ein Bild zeichnet von einer, von mehreren jungen Generationen, die die ganze Zeit nur in Cafés und Bars sitzen. Also das kenne ich eigentlich nur von solchen Krypto-Influencern wie Karl S., die sagen, kein Wunder, dass hier nichts mehr läuft. Alle sitzen nur da und trinken Kaffee und hasseln nicht mehr. Also diese Mentalität ist jetzt auch bei den Blättern wohl angekommen. Jenny greift jetzt diese Frage, ja was würde ich tun, dann mal kurz auf.
Grundsätzlich zu der Frage, was würdet ihr denn machen, wenn hier der Russe kommt. Das Allererste, was ich machen würde, ist dafür sorgen, dass mein Bruder nicht irgendwo an irgendeiner Front fällt. Nicht für diesen Staat. Ganz ehrlich.
Und nicht für diesen Staat.
Nicht für diesen Staat, nicht für Scholz und nicht für Merz. Warum auch?
Jetzt noch einmal Albrecht von Lucke antwortet. Man muss jetzt sehr genau darauf achten, was er sagt.
Der Staat ist doch mehr als Scholz und Merz. Ich gebe dir ja recht.
Stimmt, aber ich habe auch nur einen Bruder.
Der Staat wird es irgendwie schon wieder überleben. Meine Kollegin, die sehr geschätzt ist, fragt sich das auch. Aber die Frage ist eben eine andere. Dann frage dich doch mal, du musst dich doch auch die Frage zumindest an dich heranlassen, wie wollen wir in diesem Lande leben? Und wollen wir zum Beispiel, es geht doch gar nicht um deinen Bruder, dein Bruder, oder ist er dein Bruder?
Wehrhaft, kriegstüchtig, oh, die sind immer abgeschnitten. Fehlen da noch Pointen von Albrecht? Warte.
Kriegen wir das anders? Weil wir müssen diesen Clip wirklich in ganz Söhne umdrehen, um das in Reihenform... Wir müssen also da unbedingt nochmal nachfassen.
Wir rufen...
Kommen wir hier in die Untiefen von Stefan's Programmen?
Nein, nein, wir spielen den original von dir gesendeten Clip. Oh, Moment, gebt uns einen kurzen Moment.
Ja, das ist live hier.
Ja, das ist live auf...
Aber ich finde es ja sowieso beeindruckend, dass Stefan das alles hier koordinieren kann. Wenn ich es allein machen würde, gäbe es halt keinen Podcast.
Albrecht von Lucke. Warte mal. Ah nee, wir sind ja noch im März-Moment. Wir müssen natürlich darauf achten, dass wir uns nur mit den aktuellen Clips belästigen. Gestern.
Genau, jetzt Bruder-Teil 2 hören wir jetzt mal.
Bruder-Teil 2, okay. Wir achten darauf, wenn der jetzt nicht vollständig ist, war es nicht ich.
Das ist doch mehr, der Staat ist doch mehr als Scholz und Merz. Ich gebe dir ja nichts.
Ja, stimmt, aber ich habe auch nur einen Bruder.
Der Staat wird uns irgendwie schon wieder überlegen. Anett würde doch genauso, meine Kollegin, die sehr geschätzt ist, fragt sich das auch, auf ihr Kind bezogen, der ein junger Junge ist. Aber die Frage ist eben eine andere. Dann frage dich doch mal, du musst dich doch auch die Frage zumindest an dich heranlassen, wie wollen wir in diesem Lande leben? Und wollen wir, zum Beispiel, es geht doch gar nicht um deinen Bruder, dein Bruder, oder ist er dein Bruder?
Also ich finde, das ist eine sehr gute Pointe. Dein Bruder, dein Bruder.
Aber eigentlich geht die Pointe noch weiter, denn es kann ja sein, dass andere gehen wollen. Ach wollen? Dass es die Brüder der anderen sind. Also die Brüder der anderen kann man doch schicken. Nur das Problem ist ja immer, bei so einem Krieg irgendwann sind die Brüder der anderen ausgegangen. Und wie macht man dann eigentlich weiter? Ja, Thema Wohnen. Albrecht von Lucke ist irgendwie nicht so ein großes Thema.
Diese Fragen, wie stehen wir eigentlich zu diesem Land? Was wollen wir hier verteidigen? Wie würde es uns ergehen, wenn wir in eine ähnliche Situation wie die Ukraine geraten? Das sind doch alles Fragen, die eine junge Generation jetzt angehen müssen. Und nicht die Fragen, die nur darin bestehen, hat der Staat für eine billige Wohnung zu sorgen. Das ist doch alles... Jetzt muss ich aber auch mal... Das ist eine Anspruchshaltung, die du hier artikulierst, in einem Staatswesen, ich sag's mal letztes, das offensichtlich für weite Teile der Welt so attraktiv ist, dass es Menschen aus aller Herren Länder anzieht.
Oder nicht.
Auch nochmal der Pull-Faktor hier, offenbar. Weil hier so günstiger Wohnraum ist, kommen vor allem die vielen Flüchtlinge zu uns.
Wir können ja die Zahlen nochmal referieren, weil die ja wirklich super wichtig sind. Also eine Branche mit 6,5 Millionen Beschäftigten, die ein Steueraufkommen von 140 Milliarden Euro pro Jahr erwirtschaftet, sagt von sich Auftragseingang minus 50 Prozent. Und dann nehmen wir Hamburg in dem Beispiel punktuell minus 80 Prozent. Und Schuld sind jetzt diejenigen, die eine Wohnung suchen. Also die eigentlich auf der Nachfrage-Seite sagen, wo ist eigentlich meine Wohnung, warum wird hier nicht gebaut?
Sie mit so einer Anspruchshaltung daran gehen, ja.
Da könnte man ja schon fast sagen, Albrecht, wollen wir nicht das mit dem Krieg überspringen und direkt auf das Trümmerfrauen-Ding gehen und erst mal bauen? Ansonsten wird gar nichts mehr passieren.
Wir hören jetzt zum Abschluss vielleicht die Begründung für all das. Also das geht noch sehr viel länger. Das habe ich jetzt nicht alles mitgebracht. Ich denke, das ist so klar geworden. Die Gemüter sind der Hitz.
Gott sei Dank wird gerufen. Also ihr könnt sie ja hören. Vier und halb Stunden.
Ja, genau. Ein Mission-Podcast, kann man alles nochmal nachhören. Jetzt aber, Albrecht von Lucke, noch einmal zum Schluss. Und jetzt hat er seinen ultimativen Beweis dafür, dass die Jugend sich politisch nicht engagiert.
Das ist die Lage in Deutschland. Und wenn man sich auch dabei nicht einmal hier auf die Hinterbeine stellt, ich reise durch viele Städte und halte Vorträge noch und nöcher, ich spreche nur vor Alten 60 plus. Die Jungen mögen Twittern und TikTok machen in ihren Blasen, wie sie wollen.
Ja, vielleicht ist das Problem, dass Albrecht von Lucke immer nur vor 60-jährigen plus spricht. Deswegen, zum einen soll es ein Aufruf zum Cancel sein, zum anderen aber auch gar nicht. Also ich empfehle ab sofort allen jungen Menschen, geh zu den Vorträgen von Albrecht von Lucke und sag mal, hallo, ich habe so eine ganz verrückte Anspruchshaltung, ich hätte gerne ein WG-Zimmer.
Oder ich würde gerne wissen, was genau verteidige ich nochmal in diesem Krieg, woanders? Was ist da? Gut, wir merken also, wir müssen dringend anders debattieren. Ihr seht es hier schon, das ist ja so eine Meldung des Monats oder aus dem Monat gewesen. Scholz für Abschiebung nach Afghanistan. Und ich habe schon gedacht, das kann man natürlich so stehen lassen, also es einfach so hinwegschwemmen lassen. Morgen kommt ja wieder eine Deutschlandfunk-Tag-Zusammenfassung oder eine Tagesschau, wie auch immer. Aber dieses Thema hat ja dann doch so ein paar Beine gekriegt. Denn wenn der Ampel-SPD-Kanzler sagt, wir sollten jetzt mal was machen und plötzlich sagen die CDUler, ja das stimmt, dann wird es natürlich kritisch. Also Hendrik Wüst, Ministerpräsident in NRW, sagt, Kontaktaufnahme mit den Taliban und unser Landesherr hier, ihr seid gerade unter seinen Fittichen Boris Rhein, sagt, ja Gespräche mit den Taliban.
Es finde ich erstaunlich, dass man mit den Taliban offenbar gut verhandeln kann, während es ja ganz viele andere gibt, wo man immer sagt, mit denen kann man nicht verhandeln. Will die Namen jetzt nicht nennen, aber ist doch verwunderlich.
Offenbar geht das jetzt. Aber hier hat man ja auch klare Ziele, anders als woanders. Gut, also wir müssen hier etwas klären. Zum Beispiel die Frage, was machen wir jetzt mit solchen Themen, die im Raum stehen. Ihr habt alle im Blick. Die Alternative ist jetzt natürlich, in Niederlande gegen Frankreich zu gucken. Ich weiß nicht, ob es Fußballfans gibt. Ihr habt euch dafür entschieden, wir machen jetzt ein bisschen Unterricht. Also ich verdeutliche ein Problem. Dann löse ich es, indem ich einen neuen Grundbegriff postuliere. Und dann gehen wir das anhand mehrerer Übungen gemeinsam durch. Also, bleiben wir mal bei diesem ersten Thema. Taliban, irgendwas Taliban. Wir reden jetzt mit der Taliban. Wer sind die Taliban? Das wissen wir gar nicht. Also die aktuellste Meldung, die ich fand, ist Christoph Reuter. Der hat ja dieses Buch über den dunklen, den schwarzen Staat. Also der hat ja dieses legendäre IS-Buch damals geschrieben. Ist also für uns der namhafte Autor. Er ist im Spiegel tätig und hat 2021 gemutet, mit dem Mutmaß, dass es so ungefähr die Taliban-Regierung aussehen dürfte. Wenn wir uns jetzt alle die Augen zuhalten und fragen, wie sieht sie nochmal aus? Bärte, Kopfbedeckung und ansonsten mehr weiß man nicht. Deswegen gehen wir dem jetzt mal nach. Er hier ist von einer undatierten Aufnahme Haibatullah Achund Sada. Also da steckt so eine gewisse Edelsbrücke mit drin, finde ich. Achund Sada ist der Chef der Taliban. Mutmaßlich. Man weiß es nicht so genau. Auch Christoph Reuter weiß es nicht so genau. Boris Rhein hofft, dass er das ist. Er will ja mit irgendwem reden. Der allerdings regiert nicht selbst, sondern der hat ja so ein paar Handlanger, hier zum Beispiel. Wir lassen ihn mal namenlos, weil es ja auch egal. Aber das ist der aktuelle Regierungschef von Afghanistan. Soweit mir bekannt ist. Ich habe auch Claude gefragt. Das ist Wissensstand. Aufklärung weiter. In den Schweizer Publikationen die Mirdlake Crew von Kabul. Allerdings steht hier auch nicht unter dem Bild. Da steht halt einfach 2021 Associated Press. Also es ist halt so das aktuellste Bild, was auch die Profis gefunden haben. Und ich frage mich jetzt, wenn die sagen, ja ja, der Scholz, der Dreyf, wir müssen nach dahin abschieben. Dann müssen wir erst mit denen reden. Also wissen wir jetzt ungefähr, wie die aussehen. Wie reden wir denn mit denen? Wir haben ja, ich sag mal, eine gewisse Mode für politische Diskussionen. Entweder wir treffen uns hier und lachen dann so ein bisschen drüber. Oder wir gehen halt ins Parlament, da wo wirklich über Themen gesprochen wird. Und falls ihr noch nicht wusstet, was eine Bild-Tonschere ist, ihr lernt das jetzt kennen. Also wir hören jetzt Bärbel Bas. Wie ich mir vorstelle, dass deutsche Politiker glauben, so sieht eine Kontaktaufnahme mit dem Taliban aus. Man stellt also das Thema vor.
Ich rufe auf Tagesordnungspunkte 8a bis 8c sowie Zusatzpunkt 2. Beratung von Beschlussempfehlungen des Ausschusses für Inneres und Heimat zu dem Antrag der Fraktion der CDU-CSU mit dem Titel Abschiebehörden beseitigen, Ausreisepflichten konsequent durchsetzen, sowie zu zwei Anträgen der Fraktion der AfD mit den Titeln Nationale Kraftanstrengungen zur Abschiebung von abgelehnten Asylbewerbern und die Zeitenwende in der Migrationspolitik mit einer Rückführungsoffensive 2023 einleiten, sowie Beratung des Antrags der Fraktionen CDU und CSU mit dem Titel Irreguläre Migration an den Grenzen steuern, begrenzen und kontrollieren. Über die Beschlussempfehlungen zu dem Antrag der Fraktion der CDU und CSU werden wir später namentlich abstimmen. Für die Aussprache wurde eine Dauer von 68 Minuten vereinbart.
Also wir haben jetzt eine Minute gehört. Den Taliban will sie jetzt 68 Minuten zumuten. Ich würde sagen, das ist ein Fall fürs Wettbüro. Schafft man es, bevor einer schießt? Die Sitzung auch wieder zu beenden, oder laufen dann einfach alle fluchtartig auseinander?
Es ist ja auch in der Logik doch ganz interessant, dass die CDU ja so sehr darauf abzieht, dass man dann so Straftäter, also die krassen Straftäter abschiebt und die dann den Taliban gibt, wo die ja vermutlich dankend aufgenommen werden, um dann eines Tages wieder zurückgeschickt zu werden, aber dann möglicherweise ein bisschen radikalisierter noch als zuvor.
Und besser bewaffnet als mit dem Messer vielleicht.
Ja, und da bin ich gespannt, welche Debatte dann geführt wird.
Ja, und bevor die dann wieder zurückreisen, hier ist ja noch, man will ja noch eine Mitgift mitgeben. Also nicht nur kommen die Leute hier wegen Polizistenmord, der schon mal an sich ein Mord ist, ins Gefängnis, sondern nein, wir schicken sie nach Afghanistan als Märtyrer und schicken auch Geld mit. Also so ungefähr stellt sich die Ampel.
Das ist der Vorschlag von Boris Rhein, wir müssen auch Geld in die Hand nehmen.
Wir müssen auch Geld in die Hand nehmen. Ich hab mich dann gefragt, wie sieht das aus? So.
Für die, die das hinten nicht so sehen können, wir sehen hier Christian Lindner mit einem Batzen Geld wickelt.
Steht dann in Kabul am Flughafen. Wir wissen ja noch, wie Kabul Flughafen aussah, oder? Das sind die letzten Bilder, die wir haben, vom Kabul Flughafen. Also bisher scheint mir das alles sehr undurchdacht zu sein, weshalb wir jetzt nach dieser Themenvorstellung übergehen in das Erörtern, Erarbeiten und Postulieren eines neuen Grundbegriffes. Und ich dachte mir, wir brauchen jetzt neue Kräfte. Hört hier jemand methodisch inkorrekt? Wenige nur. Okay, gut, dann sage ich auch die, die es hören, lasst euch für den nichts sagen. Wir brauchen jetzt die Kraft der Bergkristalle. Wir brauchen jetzt Schwurbel. Wir brauchen jetzt alle Mittel, die uns helfen. Denn, stellt sich raus, man kann ja, und wir haben jetzt schon festgestellt, das, was wir eben gehört haben von der Ampel und der CDU, das sind totale Mumpets. Wir können ja mittlerweile aus allen Mumpets noch das Beste rausholen. Ich habe also Claude gesagt, ich brauche einen neuen Grundbegriff für politische Debatten. Ich möchte etwas abstrahieren, aber es ist eigentlich nicht richtig. Ich will es so runter transformieren auf die erste pragmatische Ebene, da wo man so handlungsorientiert darüber redet. Und dann hat Claude gesagt, ja dann nenn das doch Kristallieren. Und da habe ich gefragt, warum denn Kristallieren? Und dann hat mir Claude die kleine Liste aufgearbeitet. Klare Kante. Ein Kristall hat eine klare Kante. Und was politische Diskussionen brauchen, ist klare Kante. Und zwar insbesondere wenn Hendrik Wüst, Boris Rhein, Kurs statt Chaos und so. Also klare Kante, schon mal gegeben. Transparenz, wir müssen transparent, wir müssen verstehen und übereinkommen, was wir diskutieren. Ein Kristall. Kristalle können klarer sein als Glas. Hart und beständig, ja, ist durchaus sinnvoll. Wir könnten durchaus mal so argumentieren, dass die Argumentation, der wir folgen, auch in einem Monat noch Bestand hat und nicht hinweggefegt wurde, weil Karamioska irgendwie sich fürs Golfen oder das Jagen interessiert. Geordnet und strukturiert, also ein Diamant liegt wirklich sehr geordnet und sehr strukturiert vor. Ich habe keine Ahnung davon, aber soweit ich weiß, sind diese Moleküle wirklich ganz geordnet.
Ganz vorsichtig, wir haben hier ziemlich viele Naturwissenschaftler. Dann kann ich dir nämlich nachher an der Tür wieder was anhören. Dass Stefan da wieder, ich soll das doch mal bitte korrigieren und so weiter.
Ist ein Diamantzüchter hier. Diamanten sind ja auch Kristalle. Niemand hier? Dann können wir einfach alles erzählen. Also die sind ganz geordnet und strukturiert. Diese Moleküle legen ganz ordentlich vor. Und facettenreich, wir können sie natürlich schleifen, wie wir wollen. Sie bleiben ihre Eigenschaft als transparenter, geordneter, strukturierter, hartbeständiger, klare Kante, Diamant treu. Und scharfkantig können sie auch sein.
Und weißt du übrigens, dass im Werke von Ernst Jünger der Begriff Kristallisation auch eine wichtige Rolle spielt. Gerade in den Zweiten Weltkriegstage-Büchern, Strahlungen.
Der ist also schon politisch aufgeladen. Darüber hat mich der Claude nicht empfohlen.
Ja, in gewisser Weise, da musst du nochmal nachfahren. Was hätte eigentlich Ernst Jünger dazu gesagt?
Ich habe Claude dann einfach gefragt. Du hast mir gesagt, Kristallisieren ist der Grundbegriff. Also was heißt das jetzt? Politische Diskussionen kristallisieren. Ich denke dann selber nicht mehr darüber nach, sondern lasse Claude da einfach ein paar Sachen aufschreiben. Und es stellte sich raus, die Liste ist gar nicht so kurz. Ihr müsst jetzt nicht alles lesen. Also, erstens, Nebensächliches und Abschweifungen werden weggelassen. Wenn wir also eine politische Diskussion kristallisieren, dann lassen wir das Nebensächliche weg.
Also, das heißt, ein Sprechen ohne Präambel mit anderen Worten. Also, wir kennen das.
Wir kommen gleich zum Punkt.
Es sind hier alle unter dem Bekenntniszwang. Wir müssen also erstmal genau nochmal sich verorten, nochmal aufs Grundgesetz schwören. Und erst dann kann man vielleicht auch einen Vorschlag machen, ob man den einen oder anderen Krieg vorzeitig beendet. Und diese Art ist ja, also das ist ja das Nebensächliche, immer nochmal dranfügen. Oder ist es natürlich auch so in der Reihenrhetorik, wie wir jetzt eben bei Albrecht von Lucke gesehen haben, in dem er immer nochmal sagt, der entscheidende Punkt aber ist?
Ja, wir wollen es polemisch sagen, aber von Herzen meinen, ab jetzt nebensächliche Abschleifung weg. Zweitens, straffe Moderation. Also Zeit, wichtiger Punkt.
Also sowas, wie Michel Friedman macht. Das ist ja straffe Moderation.
Ja, wir kommen auf die Bühne und sagen, beherrscht der Mensch die Sexualität oder die Sexualität den Menschen? So war das in der Oper. Das war der Einstieg von Friedman bei seinem Gespräch zum Tannhäuser. Und dann saß die 30 Jahre lang lehrende, forschende, publizierende Psychoanalytikerin, Psychoanalytikerin, und meinte, na, da muss ich drüber nachdenken. Und das hat sie dann so lange gemacht, dass er nach einer halben Stunde sagte, aber sie sind doch ausgebildet, oder? Vor Publikum. Na ja, also straffe Moderation. Michael Friedmann ist da durchaus der richtige Typ. Präzession in der Argumentation. Hängt natürlich mit den ersten beiden zusammen. Wenn Punkt eins und zwei schon gut laufen, ergibt sich Punkt drei von alleine. Außerdem, das finde ich wieder, das ist Claude Raffinesse, Positionen klar herausarbeiten. Also nicht mitbringen und durchkämpfen, sondern, ja, ja, du hast eine Meinung, das ist auch schon klar, aber jetzt schweifen wir mal bitte nicht ab von dem Thema, über das wir reden wollen, sondern wir wollen ja jenseits der Meinung kristallisieren. Wir erarbeiten jetzt Positionen. Fünftens, Prinzipientreue. Wir bleiben den Prinzipientreue und schaffen damit Variationen der Meinung. Also sehr wichtige Punkte. Zurzeit hier im Bilde, wir haben den Grundbegriff kristallisieren postuliert. Jetzt überprüfen wir das anhand dieses Bildes. Welches politische Thema wurde hier kristallisiert? Ihr könnt reinrufen, falls ihr Vermutungen habt.
Also wir sehen einen kleinen Jungen auf einem Fahrrad.
Kärswände.
Rechts und links parken oder fahren Autos.
Kinderarmut, Radwege. Also ist eins der strittigsten Themen Tempolimit. Bei Tempolimit denken wir doch bisher an Autobahn, Porsche, was auch immer. FDP, irgendwas. Stellt sich raus, Tempolimit ist gar nicht das große Thema. Der Autobahn und das Porsches. Man kann ruhig weiter mit seinem Porsche auf der Autobahn 300 fahren. Da wo das noch geht, wenn überhaupt. Also es ist ja schon durch natürliche Regen, Stau, was auch immer. Das ist nicht der Diskussion wert.
Stau nennst du natürlich. Dann würde ich sagen, das ist Wartungsstau oder Investitionsstau. Das ist nicht Regen.
Als nicht Führerscheinhaber habe ich nur mitleidige Nicht-Kommentare dazu. Leute stehen also im Stau. Nein, Tempolimit ist ein Thema für Fahrradfahrer in der Stadt. Denn wir stellen fest, ah, 40% mehr Radfahrer als noch vor 10 Jahren verunglücken, 474 sterben, 100.000 werden in Unfälle verwickelt. Wer ist schuld? Also in zwei Dritteln sind die Fahrradunfälle mit Kollisionen mit Autos. Und in 75% dieser Fälle sind die Autofahrer schuld. Tempolimit, also haltet euch nicht auf bei der Tempolimit-Diskussion mit Autobahn und Porsche. Lasst Ulf Poschert anruhen. Wir wollen hier die französische Paris-Revolution. Wir wollen auch ruhige Straßen. Tempolimit 20 wurde zum Beispiel in Frankfurt diskutiert, Innenstadt, halte ich. Dafür, dass ich weiß, ich fahre mit 23 kmh mit meinem E-Bike an meinen Ufer entlang und die Lamborghinis neben mir sind immer gleich auf, kann man auch einfach sagen, jetzt fahren wir alle 20. Und dafür ist die Ampel immer grün. Also es wäre ein Null so ein Spiel in der Ansicht. Bloß, wir hätten halt weniger Fahrradtote. Okay, dieses Thema Tempolimit, da habt ihr noch nicht so gut performt. Wir probieren das nächste, also jetzt wirklich den Kristallisierungsmein.
Darauf würde ich mich einlassen, auf diesen Gedanken, dass das Tempolimit in einer Stadt durchaus etwas ausmachen kann. Und das mit den Autobahnen nochmal anders ist.
Du willst wieder Kommentare beruhen?
Nein, nein, nein, ob das Tempolimit 20...
Ach, doch, Wolfgang sagt noch was zum Tempolimit. Ihr dürft ihn direkt jetzt gleich...
Ich muss ja noch in den Saal irgendwie verlassen können nachher. Also 20 ist schon sehr, sehr wenig.
Ja, ich weiß.
Will ich nur sagen.
20 ist...
Es gibt ganz einsame Klatscher hier. Aber ich sehe hier tatsächlich einen Spielraum. Und das geht aber dann auch in einem Zusammenhang, der so aussieht, dass man auch entsprechende Radwege hat. Also diese Unfälle entstehen ja nicht nur aufgrund des Tempos, sondern diese entstehen ja auch, weil die Fahrradfahrer ständig gezwungen sind, mal auf den Bürgersteig, mal auf der Fahrbahn zu fahren, um mal sich irgendwie durchzuschlängeln. Und dass das natürlich Unfälle produziert, ist völlig klar.
Ich würde sagen, die Straße, und damit meine ich jetzt konkret die Fahrbahn, wir haben es ja kristallisiert, wir lassen Nebensächlichkeiten weg, die Fahrbahn ist jetzt frei für alle. Auch Kinder auf dem Fahrrad, wenn sie 10 kmh fahren, Überholverbot, müssen alle 10 kmh fahren. Für diese eine Minute, wo der Jungheitsraum fällt. Okay, wir probieren das beim nächsten Thema. Jetzt bitte wirklich kristallisieren, ja? Lass den Bergkristall wirken, keine Angst vor Schwurbel. Was sagt uns dieses Bild? Welches Thema wurde hier kristallisiert?
Wir sehen da eine junge Frau am Meer mit einem Cocktailglas, irgendwie sowas wie Aperol Spritz darin.
Ökologischer Fußabdruck, Vermögenssteuer. Frauenquote, im Urlaub nur eine Frauenquote.
Also die Dame hat viel Schmuck an, ja.
Wohlstandsverwahrlösung? Ok, ein Versuch noch, bisher war es nicht dabei. Influencer. Influencer, nein? Sehr guter Hinweis. 4 Tage Woche, also all das nicht. Wir hatten eine große Diskussion, wir haben sie auch bei uns im Podcast schon aufgegriffen. Es ist Bürgergeld und Totalverweigerung. Denn wir fragen uns ja immer die ganze Zeit, wie viele Totalverweigerer gibt es eigentlich? Und wir fragen uns nicht, wie sehen sie aus? Also wie viele Bürgergeldverweigerer gibt es eigentlich? Und hier habe ich Zahlen gefunden. Also im vergangenen Jahr 2023 gab es in 11 Monaten 13.838.000 Menschen, denen das Bürgergeld so gekürzt wurde, dass man von Amtswegen feststellt, ja, das sind Totalverweigerer. So, 13.000 machen dieses Kraut fett, wenn jetzt Christian Dürr kommt und sagt, wir wollen 50 Milliarden sparen. Ich würde sagen, nö, nicht. Also vielleicht 0,3% oder so, keine Ahnung. Also verschwindend gering. Also 13.838 Menschen sind Totalverweigerer. Aber 809.000 Menschen können in Deutschland einfach von ihrem Vermögen leben, müssen also nicht arbeiten. Falls ihr jetzt denkt, aber die werden auch trotzdem arbeiten, oder? Jaja, die werden schon was machen, von dem sie sagen, das nennen wir Arbeiten. Aber die fallen nicht in diese Kategorien, wo die Handelskammer oder wer auch immer kommt und sagt, ich brauche hier mal Bürgergeldempfänger. Denen wird viel zu viel Anreize gegeben, nicht zu arbeiten.
Wir schauen uns das nachher an, denn es wird um passives Einkommen gehen. Und da spielt diese kleine Gruppe durchaus eine Rolle.
Ja, also diese 809.000 im Vergleich zu 13.000, wenn man das Thema ordentlich kristallisiert, redet man nicht über Bürgergeld. Und insbesondere wenn man einen Trend hinterherjagt. Denn hier stellten wir fest, vor 10 Jahren waren es 415.000 Menschen, die von ihrem Einkommen leben konnten. Wir haben ja gehört, dass Merkel die Zahl der Millionäre in Deutschland, und das ist dann nicht einfach die Ausrede, weil die Immobilienpreise so gestiegen sind, die Zahl der Millionäre wurde verdoppelt auf 1,3 Millionen. Das ist einfach der Trend der Zeit, dass zu viele Menschen oben rausfallen aus dem Erwerbspotenzial. Und nicht unten. Also unten ist nichts mehr abzugrasen. Gut, jetzt drehen wir den Spieß um nach zwei Themen, in denen ich für euch kristallisiert habe. Jetzt kristallisieren wir gemeinsam, denn bisher hat es ja noch nicht so gut funktioniert. Typisches Bild. Man weiß noch nicht, dass es KI gibt und braucht ein illustrierendes Foto. Und wir sehen als Thema, ich lese euch vor, falls es zu klein ist, in einem Ranking, dass die Standortfaktoren vom Staat vergleicht, fällt Deutschland dieses Jahr auf Rang 24 zurück. So, wie würden wir jetzt kristallisieren Standortfaktoren? Und wie wurde hier abgebildet? Was sehen wir? Jemand stellt Stahl her. So, ist, in Deutschland wird Stahl hergestellt, ein Standortfaktor für Deutschland? Oder könnte man den auch irgendwo anders kaufen? Vielleicht von den 400 Millionen Tonnen Überproduktion in China oder so? Also es ist irgendwie ein bisschen merkwürdig. Zum Beispiel. Also ganz schön viele Sachen liegen einfach so da. Und die Autoindustrie hat ja auch recht spät das festgestellt. Also wir könnten auch selber Batterien herstellen. Wir müssen die gar nicht nur als Commodity kaufen. So ist das aber beim Stahl. Also beim Stahl muss man jetzt nicht dem Saar-Stahlwerk hinterher trauern und nochmal eine Milliarde hinterher schießen, sondern da kann man auch einfach Stahl kaufen. Klima unschädlich, schädlicher ist er dann auch nicht. Ich hab dann mal nachgeschaut, Stahl, selbst die Stahlbranche selbst sagt, bei uns arbeiten nur 80.000 Menschen. 80.000 Menschen, das sind 10% eines Jahrgangs, aber man arbeitet ja 40 Jahre lang 40 Jahrgänge, also das sind ja 0,25% der deutschen Belegschaften, die irgendwas mit Stahlproduktion, es ist also verschwindend gering, es spielt gar keine Rolle. Stattdessen, wenn wir nach Standortfaktoren suchen, wonach hätte man also kristallisieren und dann auch visualisieren müssen im Journalismus? Wir nehmen mal unser Lieblingsthema raus. Attraktivität des Standorts für Mitarbeiter, Klammer auf Wohnqualität. Albrecht. Albrecht, wo auch immer du uns zuhörst. Kultur- und Freizeitangebote. Kann man mal in die Case gehen oder gibt es nur noch Podcasts für 40 Euro am Abend? Nein, hier für 25. Opernkarten, gestern schon wieder 121 Euro. Das zahlt ich nicht für einen großen Standortvorteil. Das wäre eigentlich witzig gewesen, wenn man sagt, Standortvorteile, Deutschland rutscht ab und dann Oper Frankfurt illustrieren. Das wäre es eigentlich gewesen. Nach Kristallisierungsmaßgaben wäre es viel besser gewesen. Okay, dann kristallisieren wir noch.
Wir haben ja im Prinzip da diesen besonderen Konflikt zwischen einer alten Industrie und einer neuen Industrie. Also die Stahlindustrie mit ihrer guten Verankerung in den Familienunternehmerverbänden, mit ihrem guten Draht zu CDU und FDP. Kann es natürlich schaffen, dass jede Transformation erstmal abgebremst oder gar ganz gestoppt wird, damit diese Stahlproduktion weiterläuft und das Rückgrat erhalten bleibt, das ja so wichtig ist für die deutsche Industrie. Während wir aber zugleich ganz viele junge Unternehmen haben, die über innovativere Technologien nachdenken, die auch resilient sind in Anbetracht des Klimawandels zum Beispiel, das ist aber etwas, was konfligiert mit den alten Interessen. Und deswegen haben wir jetzt gerade nicht nur so einen Generationenkampf, sondern wir haben dann auch wirklich das alte Geld gegen das neue Geld, bzw. viel Neues kann nur dann entstehen, wenn altes Geld sich bereit erklärt, da auch mal zu investieren. Denn dadurch, dass sich das alte Geld auch bei den alten Unternehmen so sehr angesammelt hat, oder die nur noch diese Family Offices haben, ist natürlich diese Schlagrichtung ganz klar da. Und dann wird es noch verknüpft mit so einem ideologischen Kampf, weil das Bild ist, dass einem natürlich als erstes in den Sinn kommt, deutsche Industrie, ja dann denkt man an Stahl. Das ist sehr, sehr einleuchtend, dass diese Assoziation direkt kommt. Und das Problem ist aber, wie du sagst, man könnte darüber nachdenken, ob nicht irgendwo anders schon grüner Stahl produziert wird, ob man nicht Überkapazitäten diesen Ländern abnimmt, dass man selbst aber diese 80.000 Menschen, die dann da irgendwann freigesetzt würden, nicht woanders viel dringender gebrauchen kann. Beziehungsweise kann man ja auch da nochmal überlegen, geht die ganze Industrie gleich den Bach runter, oder gibt es da eher eine Schwächung und dann auch eine Verlagerung in einen anderen Standort. Und das ist ja das Absurde jetzt gerade mit den Elektroautos, dass man jetzt sieht, dass China preisgünstig E-Mobilität möglich machen kann. Genau das, worauf sich die deutsche Autoindustrie nie konzentriert hat, weil die sagten, wir verkaufen S-Klasse mit verlängertem Radstand. Was sollen wir denn mit einem Auto, das 18.000 Euro kostet? Damit beschäftigen uns wir irgendwann mal. Und jetzt ist das eigentlich etwas, worunter natürlich die deutsche Industrie leidet. Zugleich haben wir aber mit Blick auf den Klimawandel, das als das primäre Anliegen einstmals formuliert, Pariser Klimaabkommen usw. zu sagen, wir wollen eigentlich alles dafür tun. Und das heißt, auch die Chinesen sind da mit im Boot, um möglichst schnell in eine CO2-arme oder gar neutrale Wirtschaft zu kommen. Und es ist so verrückt, dass man jetzt hier so eine Mischung aus alten Partikularinteressen und Ideologie hat, die dafür sorgen, dass man jetzt vor dieser Deindustrialisierung, die ja durchaus auch de facto nachzuweisen ist, steht wie der Oxxon Berg und versucht jetzt mit ein bisschen Protektionismus noch irgendwas ein bisschen länger abzuhalten, zumindest bis zur nächsten Wahl.
Ja, das ist wirklich so verrückt. Ich hab mit Huemann schon vereinbart, dass wir mal über die Zeit reden in einem Podcast. Denn die Monika Schnitzer hatte das mal in so einem ganz kurzen Statement, aber da fällt das einmal wirklich wie Schuppen von den Augen. Dieser Lobbyismus und diese Institutionalisierung und das mündet ja dann in diesem, das haben wir ja schon immer so gemacht, ich weiß, wie ich einen Termin beim Bürgermeister kriege, weil mein Vater, von dem ich das Stahlwerk geerbt habe, der hat ja auch schon immer Termine gehabt. Und es ist so interessant, dass man in der Gegenwart politische Entscheidungen hat, die ganz wirkmächtig sind, richtig einprogrammiert in die DNA des Landes, weil sie einfach ganz lange zurückliegen. Was aber bedeutet, von denjenigen, die diese politische Entscheidung getroffen haben, ist vielleicht gar keiner mehr am Leben. Während heute im ganzen Bundestag 700 Leute sitzen, die auch was entscheiden und damit aber nicht durchkommen, weil die Institutionen usw. da im Hintergrund noch gar nicht wirken. Also 700 Leute entscheiden etwas im Bundestag und unterliegen aber komplett den Geistern der 500 von damals, die vor 40 Jahren irgendwas entschieden haben, wo heute keine Protokolle mehr gibt und nichts, man kann nichts nachlesen, nichts ist einfach nur sozusagen reinprogrammiert. Also das sind alles wirklich sehr merkwürdige Prinzipien.
Ja, das ist die Regentschaft der Toten Hand. Und das ist ja etwas, was relativ...
Oh, das ist die Regentschaft der Toten Hand.
Ja, diese Regentschaft der Toten Hand ist ja relativ limitiert. Also man kann ja ein Testament machen und kann da auch gewisse Bedingungen reinsetzen. Also dass das Haus vielleicht nicht verkauft werden darf oder nur unter gewissen Bedingungen und und und. Aber man kann es auch nicht übertreiben. Also man kann nicht ins Testament alles Mögliche vorschreiben. Ich kann jetzt nicht jemand ein Haus vererben und 70 verrückte Bedingungen, inklusive Flo Walzer-Spielen auf der Frankfurter Zeile oder so jeden Tag. Sowas wird schwierig. Also das wird da nicht anerkannt. Und man hat eigentlich in der Moderne versucht, zwar das Eigentum aufrechtzuerhalten und hat diese Erbengesellschaft damit initiiert. Man hat aber zugleich die tote Hand versucht zu schwächen. Und das ist bisweilen gelungen, aber in diesen Fällen ist es gar nicht gelungen.
Ich glaube bei der Frage, was kann man in ein Testament schreiben? Und du erwähnst Frankfurt und die Zeile. Also der Zeil ist glaube ich alles möglich. Du musst nur die richtige Form des Testaments wählen. Wenn du also ganz rührselig kurz vor Tode noch ein Video aufnimmst, das später als Insta-Story viral geht, dann ist alles auf der Zeile möglich. Ich habe hier ein Thema kristallisiert. Und zwar abseits von Text nur visuell. Und ihr dürft raten, welches Thema wurde hier kristallisiert? Bildung, Digitalisierung. Wenn man die Bilder richtig macht, dann scheint das viel besser zu funktionieren. Alle angedockten Journalisten, die uns zuhören, das ist der Weg. Einfach so visualisieren.
Also wir sehen Kinder in einer Schule auf dem Boden sitzen. Alles ist in Trümmern. Die Tafel kaum noch beschreibbar. Aber die Kinder haben was in der Hand.
Also wenn es heißt Digitalpakt und so weiter, wird alles ausgeblendet. Und am Ende wird ein großer grüner Haken bei Straak-Watzhänger gemacht. Die haben jetzt iPads. Das ist der Digitalpakt. Einmal kristallisiert visualisiert. Was für uns bedeutet, einige fragten ja immer, Wolfgang, wo gibt es deine Kappe zu kaufen? Wann droppt ihr mal den Merch? Falls wir jemals Merch machen im Podcast, gibt es bei uns Kristalle. Also wundert euch nicht, wenn wir sagen, es gibt 10 Stück. Sie kosten pro Stück 5000 Euro. Und der Drop ist morgen 6.35 Uhr. Nur ein Vorschlag, mal gucken. Wir bereden das im Backoffice.
Wir haben jetzt schon gehört, es gibt so ein paar Leute, die können ganz gut leben, ohne dass sie arbeiten müssen. Das ist doch eigentlich eine interessante Spur, der wir mal ein bisschen nachgehen sollten. Ich bin darauf gestoßen, weil kürzlich Erik Pozzoweit im OMR-Podcast war. Erik Pozzoweit ist der Gründer von Scalable Capital. Das ist ein sogenannter Neo-Broker. Den kann man dann auf dem Smartphone mit sich herumtragen und kann traden. Man kann aber auch ETF-Sparpläne anlegen. Das ist sehr viel günstiger als das bei den Hausbanken zu tun. Nun ist es ja so, dass ich jetzt hier gar nicht mich dagegen positionieren will, sondern ich will sogar unterstreichen, dass diese Neo-Broker etwas geschafft haben. Nämlich ist es so, dass den Bankkunden, die nur bei ihrer Hausbank sind, sehr gern irgendein Fonds aufgequatscht wird, der dann 2,8% Bearbeitungsgebühr hat. Das heißt, dass da wird ganz viel Rendite einfach weggefressen, die an die Bank geht und das wird dann als ganz tolles Sparen angesehen. Oder wir haben das ja auch bei Riester und Rürobrenten durchgerechnet bekommen, kürzlich von Finanzwende, die hatten da eine Studie veröffentlicht, dass das also verschwindend gering ist, welchen Ertrag man machen kann. Insofern ist diese Möglichkeit, über diese Neo-Broker auch noch privat zu sparen, sicherlich eine, wir geben hier keine Investitionstipps, aber sicherlich eine, die man mal bedenken sollte, wenn man zum Beispiel dann sieht, dass da bei den ETFs eine Bearbeitungsgebühr von 0,2 oder 0,3 Prozent sind. Insofern ist also da diese Macht der Banken ein bisschen angekratzt worden. Und das hat ja schon mal etwas. Aber interessant ist nun, dass Eric Potz soweit in diesem Podcast nicht nur erzählt, was seine App alles kann, sondern er stellt auch so allgemeinere Betrachtungen an, wie er Deutschland zum Beispiel sieht. Und das hören wir uns mal an.
Ja, aber das Gesamtpaket finde ich in Deutschland schon gut. Und ich bin auch froh, dass ich in Deutschland, weil es ist außerhalb der USA und China, ist es einer der stärksten Märkte, um auch zu gründen. Es ist die größte Volkswirtschaft Europas. Das darf man alles nicht vergessen. Also das ist mein positiver Pitch. Auf der Seite, wo ich sage, wo es mir Sorgen macht, wo wir noch viel mehr hinterher müssen, ich glaube, wir sind schon hier zu gemütlich unterwegs. Man sieht das in verschiedensten Statistiken. Eine, die jetzt im Großen Jahr diskutiert wurde, war, oder jedes Jahr poppt sie wieder auf, die feilen den Arbeitsstunden, die geleistet werden. Das ist schon ein Luxussymbol.
Du sagst, es ist nicht ganz logisch, dass überall Leute gesucht werden, aber die, die arbeiten, die sagen, wir wollen nur noch vier Tage haben.
Ja, dass man sich das so leisten kann. Das ist natürlich, vielleicht freut es einen individuell für die Leute, aber mittel- und langfristig ist das keine gute Sache.
Ja, dann sind die Renditen nicht so hoch. Wenn plötzlich eine Arbeitszeitverkürzung stattfindet, dann ist man an der Börse nicht so glücklich. Und damit sind wir schon bei diesem Problem. Wenn ein jeder auch Aktionär wird, dann sägt man ja in gewisser Weise an seinem eigenen Ast. Wenn man anfängt, über verkürzte Arbeitszeiten nachzudenken, weil man ja eigentlich eine hohe Rendite erwirtschaften will, damit sich das wieder in seinem Scalable-Portfolio zeigt. Und da merken wir schon, das ist so ein Widerspruch. Oder sagen wir eher, das ist ein Dilemma, das gar nicht aufzulösen ist. Er glaubt aber, dass man es auflösen kann, genau dadurch, dass ein jeder jetzt mit ETF-Sparen weitergeht. Wir hören da mal rein.
Manchmal vielleicht aber auch ideologisch nicht glauben wollen. Manchmal beschleicht mich fast ein bisschen das Gefühl, es gibt vielleicht auch Leute, die wollen gar nicht, dass so viele Leute am Kapitalmarkt partizipieren. Wenn die am Kapitalmarkt partizipieren, dann werden wir alle zu Kapitalisten und Lähnen. Vielleicht verliere ich sogar meine Wählerschaft, wenn alle Leute sagen, ich bestreike jetzt nicht Unternehmen, sondern ich bin Teilhaber, auch wenn ich nur ein kleiner Teilhaber bin. Ich finde es eigentlich gut, wenn wir normal weitermachen.
Wo er das so sagt, wenn ich das als Politiker sage, verliere ich vielleicht meine Wählerschaft. Dafür haben wir ein empirisches Beispiel. Die FDP hat das ja gesagt. Und dann hat sie ihre Wählerschaft verloren.
Er meint natürlich, wenn linke Politiker davor warnen und nicht so eine Privatisierung der Rente wollen, dass die das tun oder Gewerkschafter davor warnen, weil sie dann Angst haben, dass die Bevölkerung sich als Freund der Unternehmen begreift. Und tatsächlich ist das ja die Idee gewesen von Margaret Thatcher, dass jeder sich als Kapitalist versteht und damit kein Arbeitskampf mehr stattfindet. Und das ist ja schön dann für den Amazon-Lieferanten. Der braucht sich einfach nur eine Amazon-Aktie zu kaufen, glaube ich 185 Euro gerade. Und dann ist er ja Teil des Unternehmens. Warum das also noch bestreiten? Dann doch lieber noch eine Überstunde gratis mehr machen. Geht doch am Ende gut ins Portfolio ein. Also wir merken, dass das eine ganz abstruse Idee ist, die aber sehr verbreitet ist bei diesen Leuten. Und da sieht man schon, okay, es soll also darum gehen, dass man doch über diese Ausschüttungen, die man da bekommt per ETF oder diese tesaurierenden Modelle, dass man also immer mehr Vermögen anspart. Und dann sind doch eigentlich alle in einem Brot. Philipp Westermeyer, der Moderator, fragt dann am Ende noch...
Wie lange muss man dann irgendwie, weiß ich nicht, 50 Euro im Monat sparen, bis er Millionär wird? Das ist schon eine ganze Zeit, ne?
Ja, ja, haben wir ausgerechnet. Habe ich jetzt leider nicht im Kopf. Aber lustig ist, es ist machbar mit... Also du musst nicht irgendwie reich erben, um das zu schaffen. Du brauchst einen langen Zeitraum. Aber wenn du damit als Zwanziger, als Zwanzigerjäger schon anfangen, kannst du das zur Rente schaffen. Ich kann die Zahl dir nochmal nachreichen. Auf dem Kopf weiß ich es jetzt gar nicht. Aber es ist absolut machbar mit wirklich machbaren Erträgen. Also mit ein paar hundert Euro im Monat über einen langen Zeitraum schaffst du das.
Also da sind wir schon mal ein paar hundert Euro.
Die Million ist halt in 13, 14 Jahren nicht mehr eine Million von heute.
Diese dumme Inflation kommt ja auch noch hinzu. Wenn man aber ein paar hundert Euro zur Hand hat, dann geht es wohl eher. Das hat mich ja dann interessiert.
Aber er lachte ja so. Hast du Erfahrungen damit und bist mit gescheitert oder ist das...
Jeder ist damit gescheitert. Die Idee ist, 50 Euro ETF sparen und dann ist man bald in der finanziellen Freiheit. Das klang verlockend auch für mich. Ich habe dann mal so einen Rechner bemüht von Finanzfluss. Habe aber mir erst mal angesehen, wie hat sich der MSCI World, das ist ja sehr bekannt als ETF, wie hat er sich entwickelt und dann kommt man da auf so eine jährliche Rendite in den letzten 50 Jahren durchschnittlich von 7,39%. Ich habe das mal aufgerundet auf 7,5% und habe gedacht, wie lange müsste man da sparen, wenn man 50 Euro hat? So, hier, wenn man also Millionär werden will, dann muss man insgesamt 69 Jahre sparen. Dann hat man die Million. Also das heißt, man muss also sehr früh anfangen, kommt dann bei der Million raus. Ein bisschen unter einer Million, muss man sagen. Es geht ja auch noch was an Steuern dann ab. Aber das wäre jetzt also das Modell. Sollten sich die Aktien so weiter entwickeln, dann wäre man also mit 69 Jahren gut raus. Man muss aber mit 0 Jahren anfangen.
Ja, sonst wäre man ja dann schon 95.
Dann habe ich mir mal angesehen, wenn man 35 Jahre lang monatlich 650 Euro spart. Also das sind die paar Hundert Euro. In 35 Jahren wäre ja vielleicht noch so, dass man denkt, ja, mit 25 fange ich mal an. Dann bin ich mit 60 Millionär. Und muss aber dann mit 25 schon ordentlich verdienen, dass ich 650 Euro mal gerade so zur Seite legen kann. Und dann tatsächlich, wenn man sogar 650 Euro anspart, dann bleiben einem, dann kommt man tatsächlich auf eine Million. Aber 650 Euro 35 Jahre lang. Wer schafft das schon? Wir wissen, die Hälfte der Bevölkerung hat kein Geld oder Schulden. Die Sparquoten sind, wie wir gleich sehen werden, sehr gering. Wir haben jetzt hier noch eine Rechnung. Ich hab dann einfach mal geguckt, was ist denn, wenn man eine Million erbt? Das wäre ja eigentlich ganz praktisch. Ja, das ist sehr gut. Dann kommt man, nämlich wenn man das auch 35 Jahre lang, einfach keinen Euro mehr dazu steuert, sondern einfach nur diese 10 Millionen liegen lässt in einem ETF, MSCI World, dann kommt man nach 35 Jahren bei über 10 Millionen Euro an. Also wir sehen schon, weil er anfangs so sagte, es ist kein Problem, man muss auch gar kein Millionär oder so sein. Ja, aber die Millionäre haben einen ungeheuren Vorsprung und der wird dann mit Arbeit schwer einzuholen sein.
Wenn wir sagen, das Feuer-Movement, wir reden hier von diesem Bewegungsmovement von Leuten, die für finanzielle Unabhängigkeit früh ausreisen.
Und schau, ich mag...
Das FIRE-Movement. Wer kennt es? Financial Independence, Retire Early. Das ist also die Idee. Und die gibt es dann in sehr vielen verschiedenen Variationen, wie wir noch kennenlernen werden. Das ist The Money Guy Show. Dort unterhalten sie sich über dieses Konzept und überlegen, wie kommt man da überhaupt hin und was wollen eigentlich diese Leute vom FIRE-Movement. Na ja, nicht unbedingt. Dazu kommen wir aber auch noch zu den Frugalisten.
Sie mögen einfach nicht das, was sie an einem Tag an einem Tag machen. Sie wollen herausfinden, wie sie von dem, was sie tun, aus dem Weg gehen können. Sie sagen, hey, wenn ich einfach retiere, wenn ich nicht in die 9-5 Uhr klopfen würde, dann würde ich die Zeit kontrollieren, wo ich gehe, wann ich gehe, wie ich gehe. Einige Leute wollen es einfach, weil sie mehr Optionen haben.
Nun ist es ja so, dass wir hier doch auch einen Wunsch artikuliert haben. Wir haben ja das Buch von Hecklund gelesen, da ging es um die Zeit. Und jeder, der merkt, wie die Zeit verstreicht, kann nachvollziehen, dass Zeit etwas sehr kostbares ist.
Also wir alle.
Und dann stellt sich ja nicht nur vielleicht die Frage, bin ich im richtigen Job, sollte ich den noch mal wechseln, sollte ich mich noch mal umorientieren, sondern generell könnte ich mehr Freizeit haben. Eigentlich würde aus diesen Überlegungen ja auch etwas politisches resultieren in Form von, man setzt sich dafür ein, dass es eine kürzere Arbeitszeit gibt. Aber tatsächlich ist hier das Movement und sind diese Movement so beliebt, weil natürlich hier eine ganz individualistische Antwort gegeben wird, nämlich schau doch, dass du es in irgendeiner Weise schaffst, da rauszukommen. Und das bedeutet, und da sind wir immer in dieser Logik von scalable capital Gründer Potsoweit, irgendjemand anders muss ja dann arbeiten. Also das Geld vermehrt sich ja nicht von allein. Man kann das Geld irgendwo hinsetzen, aber das läuft nicht weg oder so, sondern das Geld vermehrt sich ja dadurch, dass andere dann noch arbeiten. Und dieser individualistische Ausgang aus dem Dilemma ist ja also in einer Weise präsent, in der Form, dass man eigentlich einen Klassenkampf daraus ableiten könnte. Aber genau das Gegenteil setzt ein, sondern man überlegt nur, wie kann man es auch schaffen, irgendwie an diese Spitze zu gelangen, der Nicht-Arbeitenden?
Ja, daran schließen wir dann wahrscheinlich auch an, wenn wir Nico Sems Rott Buch im nächsten Salon lesen in zwei Wochen. Denn der geht ja auch mal die Privilegien so durch und die können wir ja immer mal auf Lebenszeit zurückführen.
Wir hören mal weiter.
Es ist eine einzelne Sache. Aber jetzt ist es viel mehr verwendet. Es gibt fette finanzielle Einwanderungen, es gibt schmutzige finanzielle Einwanderungen, es gibt kostefinanzielle Einwanderungen, es gibt baristaische finanzielle Einwanderungen, es gibt schlau finanzielle Einwanderungen.
Das ist so kurz vor Religion, wir haben ja immer diese Frage mitlaufen, dass wir hier die ganzen alten Begriffe wieder rausholen, die arme Kirchenmaus, das Peinigen, wie dir macht dein Leben keinen Spaß, wenn du siehst darin keinen Sinn, peinige dich doch mal, so. Geh doch mal in den Kloster und lass alles zu Hause, was du so nicht brauchst, übrigens du brauchst nichts.
Und man kann sich auch dann einordnen. Also auch in dem Christentum gibt es ja verschiedene Abspaltungen, denen man hören kann. Es gibt nochmal andere Auffassungen, wie man dann bitte die Messe lesen soll. Und so ist es hier auch. Es gibt dann also verschiedene Möglichkeiten dieses Fire Movements. Was mir gut gefallen hat, war Fatfire. Also das sind die Leute, die einfach nur das Geld zum Fenster raushauen können, weil sie so viel verdient haben, dass gar keinen Unterschied mehr macht. Und dann gibt es aber auch Barista-Fire. Das meint, dass man für sein alltägliches Auskommen und der dann auch krankenversichert ist, noch so einen halben Tag oder drei Tage die Woche, zwei Tage die Woche irgendwo kellnert, hat damit so einen Grundstock. Und der Rest kommt dann über die ETFs oder was auch immer zusammen.
Wie heißt dieses Fire, wo man in seiner eigenen Immobilie wohnt, die die Eltern abbezahlt haben, sodass man einfach nicht diese 2000 Euro im Monat braucht, wie die Arbeitskollegen und Freunde.
Müsste man auch nochmal einen schönen Begriff begriffen. Wir kommen aber auf das Thema Mieten gleich. Jetzt haben wir es schon gehört, aber was ist danach? Gabe Bald hat auch sich diesem Fire Movement eine Zeit lang angeschlossen, aber hat dann doch wieder Abstand genommen, wie er in einem Erfahrungsbericht erklärt.
Und, und, nicht falsch sagen, ich bin nicht all das hartes Arbeit, das wir in die Arbeit gegeben haben. Aber ich denke, ich habe etwas falsch gemacht. Und ich will das am Ende dieses Videos erzählen. Einige Dinge, die ich wünschen hätte ich anders gemacht. Und wenn du um finanzielle Unabhängigkeit zu erreichen willst, Dinge, die ich glaube, dir ein bisschen helfen können. Also bin ich definitiv nicht in der FIRE-Movement geflogen.
Wir haben eine politische Bewegung, die sich genau diese Frage stellt. Was machen wir alle ohne Arbeit? Und das ist die große Orientierungslosigkeit der SPD, die sich das nicht vorstellen kann. Würde für diese Leute.
Na ja, die Sache ist ja die, wenn man so durch Frankfurt geht und es ist gerade eine EM. Und ich will jetzt nicht so ein Albrecht von Lucke-Talk hier machen. Aber es ist vielleicht tatsächlich so, dass die Sinnangebote, die gegeben werden, zum Beispiel von der UEFA, nicht ausreichen für so ein ganzes Leben im Ruhestand. Insofern muss man natürlich sich überlegen, worauf es eigentlich ankommt. Aber ich finde, dieser Gedanke ist so schlicht, dass ich ihn gar nicht hier artikulieren will eigentlich. Aber für diese Movement-Teilnehmer scheint das ganz existenziell zu sein, dass sie zum ersten Mal so grundsätzlich über das Leben nachdenken.
Vielleicht ist das ein Problem für mich, aber eine komplette finanzielle Entdeckung ist nicht mehr mein Ziel. Wenn mehr Leute in dieser Mindset-Bereich gewechselt wären, würde es nicht 20 Jahre dauern, um finanzielle Entdeckungen in der ersten Rezertät zu erreichen.
Ist das nicht anschlussfähig an dieser Diskussion, die Sloterdijk mal aufgemacht hat, dass man die notwendigen essentiellen Sachen, die man immer als würde empfindet, plötzlich ganz freiwillig macht, wenn man merkt, wie das Leben ohne sie ist, zum Beispiel Staat und Steuerzahlen?
Möglicherweise, ja. Ich denke, dass bei Sloterdijk aber auch so ein Boomer-Talk dazu kommt. Er hat ja jetzt auch kürzlich in einem Interview gesagt, dass die jungen Leute nicht mehr sich aufrappeln, um arbeiten zu gehen. Also er ist ja eigentlich da auch auf diesem Trip jetzt gerade. Das ist offenbar auch für Leute, die tatsächlich ja sehr viel arbeiten, das will ich ja auch ganz klar bei Albrecht von Lucke unterstreichen, nicht so klar, dass ihre Arbeit so sehr rund um Erfüllung ist, die ganze Zeit, also dass es gar nicht in dieser Weise als Arbeit vorkommt, wie wenn sie 40 Stunden einen Job nachgehen, der zwar lebensnotwendig ist und auch gesellschaftlich von höchster Relevanz ist, der sie aber nicht in einer Weise ausfüllt, wie das ständige Auftreten vor dem Ü60-Publikum von Albrecht von Lucke. Und man muss ja auch sich klar machen, dass man hier es mit jemandem zu tun hat, bei Stuttardyck oder auch bei von Lucke, wo sich diese Frage nicht stellt, jetzt ist irgendwas kaputt gegangen, kann ich mir das leisten, das zu reparieren oder so. Das heißt also, die sind ja über diesen Grad hinaus und können also in einer Weise ihren Leidenschaften nachgehen, ohne eine existenzielle Angst zu empfinden. Und wir haben es ja einfach bei der Mehrheit der Bevölkerung mit Leuten zu tun, die unter einer gewissen existenziellen Angst, diesmal größer, mal kleiner, stehen, dass sie ihre Arbeit nachgehen müssen. Und dass hier aber artikuliert wird, dass jemand eine Erfahrung erst mal jahrelang wachen muss, um dann zu wissen, es kommt schon darauf an, eigentlich, dass man ein glückliches Leben dann führt, wenn man auch was macht, was einem gefällt. Ist ja ganz erstaunlich, dass man dafür so lange braucht. Und daraus müsste aber eigentlich abgeleitet werden, ja wie kommt man dann eigentlich dahin, dass das nicht einzelne sich mal jetzt irgendwie erarbeiten oder sonst wie beschaffen, sondern dass man eigentlich zu einer Gesellschaft kommt, wo möglichst viele Leute möglichst viel ihren Leidenschaften nachgehen können. Und zugleich muss es natürlich gewisse gesellschaftliche Notwendigkeiten geben, die verrichtet werden. Das kennt aber auch jeder aus dem Haushalt. Du schreibst ja ein Buch über die Familie. Da sind ja auch nicht nur Stunden des Glücks, sondern auch Stunden des Wäschewaschens oder sonst wie. Und das ist dann wiederum etwas, das ist gesellschaftlich notwendig, aber die muss getan werden. Absolut. Und damit ist man aber, also diese Idee, sich so rauszuhacken, also es ist ja eigentlich immer so diese Idee, ohne eine Gesellschaft leben zu können, die kommt dann an ihre Grenzen, beziehungsweise diese Leute, die diese Fire-Movements da denen angehören, haben nur noch das im Sinn. Also möglichst schnell, so wie wir das eben mal durchkalkuliert haben, so eine ganz hohe Zahl auf dem Konto zu sehen und man höre einen Staunen.
Also, es war gut, aber als du aus dem Geld kamen, erkannte man, dass du keine Freunde hast und du allein bist.
Nein, aber die so hohe Zahl auf dem Konto. Also Freunde könnten wichtig sein. Es ist erstaunlich, welche Umwege die Leute gehen müssen dort, um wieder bei etwas anzukommen, wo man jedes 7-jährige Kind fragen könnte und das antwortet intuitiv richtig und sagt ja Freunde sind mir wichtig. Und da brauchen die jetzt erst mal einen langen Erfahrungstrip, um das wieder herauszufinden. Du hast schon den Frogalismus angesprochen. Wir wissen um die Wohnungsknappheit. Möglicherweise kann man das doch verbinden. Ist es ein Match? Wir hören mal rein. Eine ZDF-Doku über ein Ehepaar.
Wir sind so halb Minimalisten, halb Frogalisten. Wir wohnen auf 30 Quadratmeter, wo sich auch viele darüber erschrecken, wenn sie das mitkriegen, dass wir so klein wohnen. Es ist für mich kein Verzicht, sondern eine andere Lebensform.
Frogalismus bedeutet, einen großen Teil des Einkommens zu sparen, um so früh wie möglich von den Rücklagen leben zu können.
Das ist also Lustaufschub, wir sparen, sparen, sparen. Aber irgendwann können wir vielleicht nicht größere Wohnungen.
Wenn wir das wirklich durchdringen wollen, das Thema, bräuchten wir so lange, ich überlege gerade, wie lange ich mir Zeit einräumen müsste, um zu verstehen, wenn sie sagt, wir sind halb Minimalisten, halb Frogalisten.
Ja, das ist wie bei dem Konzil, als es die drei Papst gab und man auch nicht so genau wusste, was ist dann nun jetzt das Christentum, was ist denn katholisch. Ja, wir hören jetzt in eine Art Doku rein von einer Frau, die es geschafft hat. Der Clip geht ein bisschen länger, aber wir hören mal ganz zu, wie eigentlich dieses Geld auch so reinkommt. Ganz interessant.
Katrin hat als Werbemanagerin Karriere gemacht. Damals ist sie ein Workaholic, durch und durch. Jahrelang pendelt sie Woche um Woche von Hamburg nach Köln. Der Koffer, ihr ständiger Begleiter. Zu Hause ist sie nur am Wochenende. Sie verdient sehr gut, gibt das Geld aber auch gerne aus. Mit 30 beginnt sie eher planlos fürs Alter anzulegen. Groß einschränken muss sie sich dafür nie. Mit Ende 40 langweilt sich die Werbemanagerin im Job und schmiedet einen Plan. Sie spart sich einen Geldpuffer an. Ein Jahr lang will sie sich eine Auszeit gönnen, um einen neuen Job zu finden. Doch dann macht sie eine entscheidende Erfahrung. Ohne Arbeit sinken ihre monatlichen Ausgaben. Ihr wird klar, obwohl sie es nie angestrebt hat, ist sie finanziell frei. Sie kann von den Zinsen ihres Vermögens leben.
Hört sich immer so grandios an, Vermögen. Aber grundsätzlich gibt es daraus Erträge, es gibt halt Mieten. Und es gibt Ausschüttungen von Aktien, ETFs. Und daraus könnte ich meine Grundausgaben bestreiten.
Das Erste, was sie sich nach der Kündigung gönnt, Hundquitte. Früher war Katrin Marketing-Direktorin mit vollem Terminkalender. Was sie heute ist, das weiß sie selbst nicht so genau.
Hausfrau, das ist ganz schön, was dazu zu sagen. Es gibt ja noch so andere Leute, es gibt inzwischen sogar eine ganze Community von Leuten, die eben auch so ähnlich vorgegangen sind wie ich. Und wo der eine oder andere dann eben auch jetzt eben nicht mehr so einem normalen Beruf nachgeht.
Ihre To-do-Liste im selbstgewählten Ruhestand überschaubar.
Natürlich hier mit dem Hund spazieren gehen, das ist jetzt alles nicht so wirklich eine Herausforderung. Also Herausforderungen gibt es eigentlich nicht mehr so viele.
Vielleicht sollte sie mal Albrecht von Lucke sprechen, ob es noch andere Dinge zu tun gibt. Und was mir besonders gut gefallen würde, wenn sie eine ihrer Wohnungen an das Fogalistenpaar vermietet, die sich gerade auf diesen 30 Quadratmeter tummeln.
Da kriegt man auch vier unter.
Also wir merken schon, es funktioniert, wenn andere arbeiten und den Laden am Laufen halten.
Ja, dass sie Mieten so einfach im Plural sagt. Ist ja eh sehr viel Unausgesprochenes hier drin. Also Hausfrau und unausgesprochen, aber glücklich, weil sie genau weiß, wie der Hasen läuft. Und dann hat sie ja Mieten. Das ist uns mit Thomas auch aufgefallen, als wir die Wahlkampf-Clips aus Großbritannien geguckt haben, mit Rishi Sunak, der einfach immer betont, ich tu doch ganz viel für die Jungen. Man ist jetzt dem ersten Haus näher. Also nicht im Sinne von, jemand kauft sich ein Haus in einem Lippmanner drin, sondern nein, wenn der reichste Mann der Insel schon Premierminister ist und sein Amt verteidigt, dann verspricht er den Leuten, dass sie the first home. So im Sinne von, ja, danach kommt noch weitere. Ist doch völlig klar. Das ist an diesen kleinen Sachen, ich tease schon mal für mein Thema nachher noch, an diesen kleinen Sachen merkt man, das Verständnis muss man erfühlen.
Man könnte auch sagen, die sind jetzt ihre ersten Millionen näher. Genau. Und er ist der reichste Mann, er ist also reicher als der König.
Ja, diese kleine Pointe war, dass er so reich ist, dass die Leute darauf aufmerksam werden und sagen, aber ihre Frau ist doch an diesem Unternehmen beteiligt, dass davon profitiert, dass die Regierung so und so entschieden hat. Und dann sagt er, ich hab meine Frau gefragt und ihr habt ihr Büro gesagt, die sollt ihr mal nachgucken und sie stellt sich raus, ja, stimmt. Wir wussten es aber nicht.
Wenn man gar nicht mehr weiß, wo das ganze Geld liegt. Soweit ist dieses Paar, das wir jetzt hören, aus der Art Doku noch nicht.
Mit Heidis Marketing-Job kommen sie gemeinsam auf über 100.000 Euro im Jahr. Auch wenn sie schon lange anlegen, wird es dauern, bis sie zumindest einen Teil ihres Einkommens durch Zinserträge und Dividenden ersetzen können. Und auch das Anlegen frisst jede Woche Zeit.
Wenn ich es gut machen will, wahrscheinlich eher so 5-6 Stunden. Aber es macht mir halt Spaß, wenn andere Anne Will gucken, lese ich mir was über Beyond Meat oder Mercado Libre durch, wie die Geschäftszahlen so sind. Ich entspanne mich da furchtbar gut. Es ist wirklich sehr, sehr, sehr entspannt.
Ich sage es ja ungern, aber dann vielleicht doch lieber Anne Will gucken oder Karin Joschka. Fünf bis sechs Stunden die Woche. Also er kann sich ja selbst mal nur den Mindestlohn berechnen. Und wie ich ja höre, da im Marketing, da sind andere Löhne fällig. Wenn er das mal so aufsummiert, was da im Monat, im Jahr zustande kommt und er würde einfach die Zeit tatsächlich arbeiten, wäre das wahrscheinlich ertragreicher. Denn da muss man ja auch nochmal dann fort soweit loben, der natürlich deutlich macht, also das Einzelaktien herauspicken und zu glauben, dass wenn man sich nur genug über eine Firma informiert hat, dann wird man schon auf Dauer outperformen können. Ist ja sehr illusorisch. Das mag bei den ein oder anderen mal geklappt haben, aber da ist man doch schon sehr nah am Glücksspiel dran. Insofern ist das also auch ziemlich vergebene Liebesmüde, der da betreibt. Wir hören jetzt noch kurz eine Studie, die wird da vorgestellt im Wall Street Journal über die Amerikaner, die jetzt die Corona-Krise hinter sich haben, Inflation kam. Und was passiert eigentlich jetzt mit den Amerikanern, so 55 plus, und ihren Ersparnissen für die private Altersvorsorge? Und wieder, das ist nicht jeder, aber das ist ein schmaler Vorgang. Das heißt, 25% gehen jetzt schon an das bisschen, was sie gespart haben, ran, weil sie sonst nicht mehr durch den Monat kommen. Also das sind einfach Realitäten, die man sich vor Augen führen muss. Wir hören jetzt einen Clip von Finanzfluss. Da geht es auch um die Frage, wie könnte man denn investieren?
Jetzt, wo wir uns die ETFs ausgesucht haben, gucken wir mal, wie viel Vermögen müsste man in diese ETFs jeweils investieren, um bestimmte Ausschüttungen pro Monat zu bekommen? Der HSBC MSCI World ETF hat eine ziemlich geringe Ausschüttungsrendite und deswegen braucht man auch entsprechend viel Vermögen, um bestimmte Ausschüttungen pro Monat zu bekommen. Für 1.000 Euro Dividenden pro Monat musst du in diesen ETF 939.000 Euro investieren. Für 2.000 Euro pro Monat brauchst du 1.893.000 Euro und für 3.000 Euro pro Monat brauchst du 2.848.000 Euro.
Also 2,8 Millionen, wenn man dann mit 3.000 Euro über den Monat will, wenn man in Frankfurt lebt, weiß man ja, geht dann noch ein Drittel oder 40 Prozent für die Miete weg. Also das wäre jetzt die Idee. Da muss man aber schon 2,8 Millionen in diesem ausschüttenden ETF haben. Ich glaube, weiß jeder, was das ist? Ausschüttend und tesaurierend. Also tesaurierend heißt man spart und bekommt nichts ausgeschüttet, sondern das wird dann immer weiter Zinseszins und so größer. Ausschüttend meint, dass man also immer dann Dividenden bekommt jedes Jahr. Die fallen aber schwankend aus und dann muss man sagen, der MSC World ist da, wir gehen jetzt nicht auf die anderen ETFs ein, ist da sicherlich das solideste, aber deshalb auch das mit den wenigsten Dividenden, mit den niedrigsten Dividenden. Und dann braucht man also so enorme Summen. Und dann kann man sich einfach klar machen, okay, 2,8 Millionen Euro, die hat natürlich niemand.
Das können wir auch nachrechnen mit den Zahlen von vorn. Also wenn diese 1 Million 69 Jahre braucht, da brauchen die 2,8 Millionen, 230 Jahre.
Das ist eigentlich ungünstig. Wird immer wieder betont, man kommt anders an das Geld. Wir gucken jetzt mal gerade hier die Spar-Quote. Das ist Zahlen leider von 2013, aber ich vermute, dass sich da nichts geändert hat, bzw. ich weiß, dass sich da nichts geändert hat. Ich hatte nur keine so schöne Grafik gefunden. Hier kann man es aber noch mal ganz deutlich sehen. Also, die Leute, die die Möglichkeit haben, überhaupt zu sparen, also die ersten 30 % der Bevölkerung gar nicht, dann geht das mal los. 40 bis 60 % können dann irgendwas zwischen 100 und 1000 Euro im Jahr sparen. Ist also alles für den Sparplan so gut wie irrelevant, für die finanzielle Freiheit. Dann geht das weiter hoch. Also, wenn man zu den Top 20 gehört, also 80 bis 90 % der meistverdienenden in Deutschland, dann kann man über 8000 Euro sparen. Also, so ist die Sparkquote. Also, man kann natürlich mehr sparen, aber die Sparkquote sieht so aus. Und wir sehen aber dann, wer kann richtig gut sparen. Das oberste Prozent spart auch sehr viel, spart einfach pro Jahr 58.000 Euro. Das oberste Einkommens-Decil. Und damit sehen wir schon diese ganze Argumentation, die ganze Zeit mit passiven Einkommen. Es gibt ja etwa eine Million Videos dazu bei YouTube. Werden zwar von Abermillionen geguckt, aber es ist eigentlich nur das Phänomen von einem Prozent.
Möglichkeiten, passives Einkommen zu generieren, lassen sich im Groben in zwei Kategorien aufteilen. Kategorie Nummer eins ist, mit Hilfe deiner Arbeitskraft. In diesem Fall investierst du einmalig eine gewisse Zeit lang deine Arbeitskraft, arbeitest also quasi an einem Projekt. Welche das sein könnte, schauen wir uns später an. Und dieses Projekt funktioniert dann weiterhin entweder komplett ohne weiteren Arbeitsaufwand oder mit deutlich weniger Aufwand. Sobald dieses Projekt dann funktioniert, generiert es Einkünfte, die dann unabhängig von deiner Arbeitskraft sind. Die zweite Kategorie, passives Einkommen zu generieren, ist über Investitionen. Hier hast du dir auf die ein oder andere Art und Weise Kapital zusammengespart und investierst dieses. Und die Renditen, die du damit erzielst, die sind dann dein passives Einkommen. An dieses Kapital heranzukommen, ist natürlich die Krux an der Sache. Dieses fällt in der Regel nicht vom Himmel. Die einfachste Möglichkeit ist vermutlich die Erbschaft. Die meisten Menschen werden sich aber dieses Kapital erarbeiten, indem sie langfristig sparen und weniger konsumieren, um mehr Geld auf die Seite legen zu können. Wenn wir also auf diese beiden großen Kategorien zurückblicken, stellen wir fest, dass beide Möglichkeiten gar nicht so passiv sind. Bei der ersten muss ich am Anfang Arbeit reinstecken und bei der zweiten muss ich mich darum bemühen, zunächst einmal Kapital zu bekommen. Wenn man sich also den gesamten Lebenszyklus anschaut, ist das Ganze gar nicht so passiv, sondern es wird immer eine aktive Phase geben und dann eine eher passivere Phase zum späteren Zeitpunkt.
Ja, dieses Es fällt nicht vom Himmel. Da gibt es diese berühmte Klatten-Quant-Titelblatt-Focus-Money oder sowas.
Im Manager-Magazin, das Geld fliegt uns nicht einfach zu.
Die Leute glauben immer, dass einem das Geld so zufliegt, während wir jetzt wieder gehört haben, dass ihnen wieder ihre BMW-Dividende in Höhe von 600, 700 Millionen zugeflogen ist.
Ja, aber sie haben ja unternehmerische...
Die haben gearbeitet dafür.
Genau. Wir hören also jetzt hier nochmal ganz klar, ja, man kann da auch das mit Arbeit bekommen. Wir wissen aber, man gehört ab. Ich glaube, 5.000 Netto als Single-Einkommen im Monat schon zu den reichsten 10%.
Nee, den einkommensstärksten 10%.
Also, den einkommensstärksten 10%. Das heißt also, das mit Arbeiten und 5.000 Euro wird schon schwierig. Also, man muss schon zu den einkommensobersten Prozent gehören, dann kann das in irgendeiner Weise gehen. Das heißt, wir können es hier auch nochmal dann in einer anderen Statistik sehen. Du hast es eben gesagt, es gibt Leute, die müssen für ihr Geld arbeiten gehen. Das sind die meisten oder haben Angehörige, die arbeiten gehen und dann gibt es genau ein Prozent, das von seinem Vermögen einfach leben kann. Jetzt war das sehr viel Investitionskram, aber da ja hier zwei Autoren auf der Bühne sitzen, dachte ich, Mensch, wir müssen auch anders über passives Einkommen nachdenken. Und mir wurde sehr häufig über Instagram dieser junge Mann angezeigt und wir hören da mal rein, was er vorschlägt.
Und eine Sache verstehe ich einmal nicht. Wie kann man sich in Zeiten von ChatchieBT und Co. jeden Tag noch dazu motivieren, zu einer Arbeit zu rennen, auf die man wirklich null Bock hat, statt sich mal ein oder zwei Stunden Zeit zu nehmen und sich in die KI-Thematik einzuarbeiten. Du kannst heutzutage mit ChatchieBT irgendwelche Rätselbücher erstellen, Faktenbücher, die einfach auf Amazon KDP hochladen und veröffentlichen. Und selbst im Worst Case verdienst du damit deine 50 oder 100 Euro im Monat, replizierst du es irgendwie 20, 30 Mal und hast dir so ein schönes Einkommen aufgebaut.
Ja, passives Einkommen. Soll ich meine Abrechnung verraten? Ich bekomme ja von Surkam, vom Influencer-Buch alle halbe Jahre eine Abrechnung. Dieses Buch hat sich ja damals gut verkauft, aber jetzt ist das Buch ja zweieinhalb Jahre alt. Das heißt, das ist jetzt nicht das Buch, das laufend gekauft wird. Und dann bekommt man so eine Abrechnung nach einem halben Jahr, dass man dann 460 Euro jetzt überwiesen bekommt an Themen. Und ich habe das mal so grob überschlagen. Also ich muss mit Ole jetzt zusammen nur noch ca. 45 Bücher schreiben und dann komme ich so auf 2000 im Monat.
Ja, für mein neues Buch wurde wirklich hart verhandelt. Klingt jetzt amüsant, aber es wurde wirklich hart verhandelt, dass ich nicht mit 10% am Verkaufspreis, sondern mit 11% beteiligt werde. Also auf mich wird das Geld nämlich... Aber übrigens, woran erkennt man hier den Schwurbel? Ihr seid unsere Podcast-Hörer, ihr müsst es wissen. Woran erkennt man bei ihm den Schwurbel? Nicht die Frisur.
Es kann nur was Technisches sein.
Er glaubt, er könne das mit GPT machen und das stimmt nicht. GPT ist nicht klug, Claude ist klug.
Also einfach mit Claude die Bücher schreiben, dann wird das richtig einträglich. Passives Einkommen durch Urheberrecht ist natürlich eine tolle Sache. Zumal, wenn das eigene Urheberrecht mal verletzt wurde und man muss dann nachträglich einen Deal machen. Manche kennen vielleicht diesen Song. Da da di da da. Ja, und da gibt es folgende Geschichte dazu. Wir sehen Sting. Ja, das Ding bekommt von P. Diddy 2000 Dollar am Tag dafür, dass dieses Lied ein bisschen verwendet wurde in dieser Cover-Version.
Das ist sehr gut.
Das ist ein gutes passives Einkommen.
Mariah Carey kriegt jedes Jahr 25 Millionen überwiesen, weil ihr Weihnachtslied so läuft.
Das ist doch ganz einfach. Wir können ja auch Stefan Welthit schreiben oder wir gehen nochmal zu den Büchern.
Wir saßen dann so voll entspannt beim Spieleabend und dann hat sie mich so gefragt, das, was du da machst mit den Büchern auf Amazon verkaufen, würde ich auch gerne machen, aber ich kann nicht schreiben und ich habe keine Ahnung, was für Bücher ich veröffentlichen soll. Dann habe ich sie einfach gefragt, was sind denn so deine Hobbys? Was machst du denn wirklich in deiner Freizeit gerne? Und dann druckste sie so rum und irgendwann meinte sie dann so, ja, ich bastel super gerne. Ich mach so Weihnachtsdekoration und dann habe ich ihr gesagt, ey, Jackpot, genau dafür gibt es eine extrem gute Nachfrage. Das glauben die meisten gar nicht, dass sie mit ihren Hobbys Geld verdienen können. Aber ich habe ihr dann gezeigt, auf Amazon verkaufen sich Origami-Faltanleitungen, Hegel-Anleitungen, Weihnachtsdekorationen, Bastel-Anleitungen und natürlich hat es sich nicht umgesetzt. Ist ja häufig so, du servierst den Leuten irgendwie ein Business-Modell auf dem Silbertablett und am Ende scheitert es daran, dass niemand den Arsch hochbekommt. Aber ich glaube, wichtig ist erst mal zu verstehen, dass es so was gibt und Bewusstsein dafür zu schaffen.
Ey, das verstehe ich nicht. Arsch hochbekommen. Er hat ja doch gesagt, sie sollen nicht den Arsch hochbekommen. Wieso scheitert es jetzt daran? Ach so.
Einmal muss man doch dann das Rätselbuch machen, das jeder kaufen will. Und das ist so eine interessante Vorstellung von Buchverkäufen. Wir hatten es ja im Salon, wie gut sich Bücher verkaufen. Und es gibt 30 Leute, die mega reich durch Bücher werden und alle anderen eher nicht. Die anderen sind dann froh, wenn sie doch mal 11 Prozent bekommen. Das ist also die Realität. Aber vielleicht, Stefan, gehst du es auch vollkommen falsch an. Du beschäftigst dich jetzt schon lange mit dem Thema Familie, jetzt wechseln, gedeiht das Buch in dir. Anders denken.
Und genau deswegen brauchst du auch gar nicht das beste Buch auf Amazon, um am meisten Geld zu verdienen. Denn es heißt Best Seller, nicht Best Content. Fokussier dich doch lieber aufs Marketing, anstatt monatelang an deinem Content zu fallen. Und am Ende verkaufst du nicht mal was.
Ja, schreibst ein mega Buch und am Ende verkaufst du es nicht.
Ja, so kann es gehen. Und zum Abschluss dachte ich mir, wer kann helfen? Ja, vielleicht braucht es doch irgendeine höhere Macht, um reich zu werden. Und da bin ich auf Grace gestoßen. Und wir hören mal rein, was sie uns zu sagen hat.
Ich dachte immer, Finanzen, Wirtschaft ist super komplex. Es hat mich echt abgeschrägt. Ich hatte wirklich Respekt vor dem Thema, weil ich einfach nicht wusste, wo soll ich anfangen, wo soll ich aufhören. Deswegen habe ich ihr gar nichts gemacht. Und dann habe ich ja BWL studiert, das duale Studium, mit der Ausbildung zur Kaufhäufelversicherung und Finanzen. Und es war auch nicht immer leicht in dem Studium wirklich. Ich bin da teilweise an meine Grenzen gekommen, weil es einfach so ein neues Thema war für mich. Ich bin aber so, so dankbar für den Weg, für die Erkenntnisse, weil ich irgendwann an dem Punkt war, dass ich es einfach verstanden hatte. Ich habe verstanden, Finanzen ist gar nicht so schwer. Wenn man es einmal verstanden hat, es echt simpel ist und man auch nicht viele Tools und auch nicht viele Tabellen oder Formeln oder irgendwas braucht, um die Finanzen in den Griff zu bekommen. Man braucht nicht viel, um das Fundament zu schaffen. Man braucht nicht viel, um das biblische Fundament zu schaffen. Und ich habe mir damals wirklich gewünscht, dass jemand auf mich zukommt und sagt, Romina, hier, ich drücke dir das in die Hand, arbeite das von Anfang bis Ende durch und dann hast du das Fundament gelegt. Und dann kannst du mit Jesus noch mehr in die Tiefe gehen. Dann kannst du darauf aufbauen, weil es gibt so viel, was wir über Finanzen auch erfahren können in der Bibel, das ist wirklich stark. Nur das Fundament und das erste Verständnis und die Ordnung, das ist nicht schwer. Und genau aus diesem Punkt heraus ist der Golden Grace Finanzplaner entstanden. Genau diesen Planer hätte ich mir damals gewünscht.
Ja, nicht Best Content.
Die Bibel hilft. Viele werden jetzt hier, die investiert haben, immer morgens krampfhaft das Handelsblatt gelesen haben oder Financial Times. Falsch, in der Bibel, stets geschrieben. Zum Beispiel, wie funktioniert das eigentlich so richtig skalieren? Wo geht die Post ab?
Hier auch einfach mal so einen Kürbis-Kern. Genau, ein ganz kleiner Kürbis-Kern. Und aus dem Kürbis-Kern wird ja ein Kürbis, logischerweise. Und in dem neuen Kürbis ist dann aber ja nicht nur ein Kürbis-Kern, der auch so sein kann, dass Gott sagt, hey, pro Kürbis einfach wieder ein Kern. Nee, aber in einem Kürbis sind dann ungefähr so viele Kürbis-Kerne drin. Also so unglaublich viele neue Kerne. Und aus denen werden ja wieder Kürbisse und wieder Kürbisse. Und das ist diese Multiplikation, das ist Saat und Ernte. Es ist das Prinzip von Versorgung, wie Gott wirklich lebt und wirbt. Und das meine ich mit Saat und Ernte, weil genau das können wir auch bei unseren Finanzen erleben.
Exponentiales Wachstum, der liebe Gott hilft.
Genau. Also ich will sie ein bisschen in Schutz nehmen. Ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass andere Menschen unseren Podcast gucken. Und dann hören wir reden irgendwie über diesen Wohnbau. Und da haben diese Zahlen. Und dann sage ich, aber eins plus eins ist doch zwei, oder? Und dann denken die, nee, das kann ja nicht sein, dass das so und so. Also in deren Sicht, ja, sie hat halt Recht, müssen wir jetzt einfach mal sagen.
Ja, vielleicht ist die Schlussfolgerung, die sie daraus zieht mit den Kürbissen, nicht so ganz klar. Wir versuchen aber noch mal zu schauen, ob es noch eine andere Möglichkeit gibt. Also gehen wir noch mal ran. Jetzt der letzte Clip, was empfiehlt sie oder wie sollten wir die Sache noch mal betrachten?
Wir fehlen wirklich langsam die Worte, was Gott tut. Das Tempo ist jetzt gerade momentan enorm. Ich komme auch selber nicht mehr ganz hinterher wirklich. Und genau darum geht es ja auch in der Goldschmiede. Dass wir zu Leitern werden, die geformt werden von Gott. Ich muss auch gerade an diese eine Bibelstelle denken. Das sagt Jesus, gerade in der Endzeit sollen wir eine Frau in Erinnerung behalten und das ist Lot's Frau. Wenn ihr euch erinnert, in der Bibelstelle 1. Mos. 19, meine ich, müsste das sein, geht es darum, dass Sodom und Gomorrah von Gott zerstört wird. Und Lot und seine Frau oder seine Familie werden gerettet von Gott aus diesen Städten oder aus dieser Stadt oder der Region, sag ich jetzt mal. Und die Engel sagen zu ihnen vorher, dreht euch nicht um. Dreht euch nicht um, flieht einfach, rennt um euer Leben. Was macht Lot's Frau? Sie dreht sich um. Sie dreht sich bei der Flucht um sehnsüchtig, was sie alles hinter sich lassen muss, was in Flammen aufgeht. Und in dem Moment erstarrt sie zu einer Salzsäule. Und warum sagt uns Jesus genau dieses Beispiel in Bezug auf die Endzeit? Weil hinter uns Dinge in Flammen aufgehen werden. Auch in uns durch die Läuterung werden Dinge in Flammen aufgehen. Wir werden Dinge hinter uns lassen müssen. Gerade in der jetzigen Zeit, gerade dann, wenn Gott uns wirklich gebrauchen möchte, werden wir durchs Feuer gehen. Und Gott sagt, dreh dich nicht um. Schau nicht auf die verbrannte Erde hinter dir. Schau auf das fruchtbare Erbe vor dir. Dein Calling, deine Berufung.
Das ist Unternehmergeist. Unternehmergeist, alles hinter sich lassen, Familie, Kind, was auch immer. Hinaus ins Leben und hustlen.
Also, das ist nicht nur Unternehmergeist, das ist auch politischer Schafsinn. Denn so macht Clara Geilwitz Wohnbaupolitik. Wir drehen uns nicht um. Wir sehen ja keine verbrannte Erde. Gut, es ist recht spät. Wir wollen euch natürlich nicht auf die Folter spannen, oder? Wir haben heute gar nicht gefragt, wer das Intro in dieser Geschwindigkeit hört. Denn typischerweise ist ein Podcast 4 Stunden lang. Nur hier kann man ihn nicht verkürzen, auch 2 Stunden. Also wenn wir sagen 4 Stunden, dann sind es wirklich 4 Stunden.
Wir müssen alle ein bisschen schneller sprechen.
Genau, deshalb wollen wir uns die Frage stellen, wie fühlt ihr euch? Das ist also nicht ganz unbedeutend, wie ihr euch fühlt. Auf welcher Dimension könnte man das jetzt festmachen, wie ihr euch fühlt? Ist es hier Schwül? Drückt Schwül aufs Gemüt? Und die Dimension Content, hält die da ein bisschen dagegen oder zieht die Schwüle trotzdem runter? Das ist schon das Uneins. Zwei Dimensionen in den Raum geworfen und schon ist völlig, das Meinungsbild ist unklar. Was brauchen wir also, um uns da wieder rauszuholen aus diesem Problem? KI. KI, wir müssen alle Emotionswagens mit KI klären. Also, die KI wird für uns...
Es wird ein hartes Ja für mich, glaube ich, mit dieser KI.
Die künstliche Intelligenz, oder wie wir es etablieren werden demnächst, die elektrische Intelligenz, wird jetzt für uns... Sag uns mal so, wir machen jetzt eine Übung. Ich stelle euch Fragen. Die könnte man diskutieren, aber wir diskutieren sie einfach nicht. Sondern jeder denkt so kurz einfach für sich drüber nach und dann stelle ich schon die nächste Frage. Sehen wir bei Instagram schönere Menschen als auf der Straße? Ja, nein, vielleicht. Also ihr wisst, worauf diese Frage so ein bisschen hinausläuft. Hat uns die Technik hier schon eingeholt und gaukelt uns bei unseren Vorlieben etwas vor, was wir ohne Technik so einfach nicht sehen können. Zweite Frage. Sind Netflix-Geschichten eigentlich spannender als die Geschichten am Weihnachtstisch von Onkel... Oh, wir haben heute ein Günther-Publikum. Ich wollte Hans schreiben. Also, wir wissen trotzdem, was mit der Frage gemeint ist. Sind Literatur-Recherchen mit Clot ertragreicher als Gespräche, zum Beispiel im universitären Kontext mit der Bibliokitarin oder mit random friends, die einem sagen, ich habe dieses und jenes Buch gelesen?
Er kommt auf die Freunde an.
Ja, zum Beispiel, es kommt auf die Freunde an. Das ist eine sehr viel bessere Antwort als das pauschale Nein von hier vorne. Vertrauen wir eigentlich Google-Suchen intimere Informationen an als unseren besten Freunden oder sogar Lebenspartnern?
Was glaubst du, was ich alles gegoogelt habe für meine Haartransplantation?
Zum Beispiel. Ich habe weitere Fragen, über die könnte man diskutieren. Lachen und weinen Menschen im Kino, obwohl sie wissen, dass der Film fabriziert ist, und zwar wirklich nur, um ihnen vorzugaukeln, dass da gerade jemand gestorben ist usw. Du bist häufig im Kino? Die Leute rasten aus emotional, oder?
Ja, ich weine ja auch im Kino. Manchmal auch, weil es berührend ist, aber häufig auch aus anderen Gründen.
Okay, in den wenigen Momenten, wo es berührend ist, du weißt, es ist hergestellt, um dich zu berühren, und es berührt dich trotzdem.
Ja, das ist Identifikation.
Oh, aktuelle Frage. Was produziert eine Europameisterschaft? Ich hab euch vorhin gesagt, die Fan-Meile hier kostet 15 Millionen Euro. Und ich meine zuerst, es war ein bisschen übertrieben, 12,3 Millionen. Random wär auch okay gewesen, aber was produziert eine Europameisterschaft? Und wer jetzt sagt, Hotel-Umsätze oder sowas, das stimmt ja nicht wirklich, das ist ja nur über Banden. Was produziert eine Fußball-Europameisterschaft?
Wir sehen hier schon ideologiekritische Perspektive.
Ja, Ablenkung. Gemeinschaft. Also wir können grob sagen, außer Gefühlen ist nichts geblieben. Also die ist dann irgendwann vorbei, die Fan-Meile wird abgebaut, wir sind entweder Meister geworden oder nicht.
Vielleicht hast du die Tagesschau gesehen, als die EM losging. Da hat man noch mal so eine kleine Rückschau gehalten zum Sommermärchen. Und die Frage war tatsächlich, wird man es noch einmal schaffen, dieses Gefühl wieder herzustellen in Deutschland?
Berühren uns Bücher, deren Autoren schon starben, bevor wir geboren wurden? Und jetzt würden selbst die Kulturoptimisten sagen, ja irgendwie schon. Wir waren gestern in einer Oper, die wurde 1835 Uhr aufgeführt. Niemand mehr, der mit dem Werk zu tun hatte, ist am Leben.
Bist du dir da so sicher? Also bei mir in der Reihe, dachte ich so bei Mansten.
Hinter uns wurde wirklich sehr viel geknistert, weil man wahrscheinlich gestorben wäre. Ohne dieses Bonbon, es muss jetzt gegessen werden, wo Monika singt. Ja, warum wird in einer Oper gesungen? Du hast die Frage schon mal auf einer Bühne geklärt. Habt ihr...
Ist schwierig zu sagen. Weil sonst ein Schauspiel wäre.
Genau. Und warum gehen wir immer in die Oper und nicht ins Schauspiel?
Das hat sehr gute Gründe, das könnte ich ganz schnell machen, indem ich sage, dass das Schauspiel oft so enttäuschend ist. Sagen wir so, wir haben gestern nicht die beste Inszenierung aller Zeiten gesehen. Würde ich jetzt mal behaupten. Aber die Musik ist ja da. Wenn dann noch das Ensemble hervorragend ist, dann ist das trotzdem ein sehr schöner Abend. Wenn man aber, wie wir zum Beispiel im Schauspiel Frankfurt, eine Verhunzung als Inszenierung sehen, dann können das auch eigentlich die Schauspieler so gut sie auch sprechen mögen, wenn man ihnen gesagt hat, ihr dürft aber nur schreien, nicht mehr glattmügeln. Und deswegen ist also das Leid, das das Schauspiel verursachen kann, wesentlich größer als das, was die Oper uns antun kann.
Ja, weshalb wir, und ich hab ja gesagt gestern, meine 23. Oper, wir waren einmal im Schauspiel und sind in der Pause gegangen.
Aber wir wollen es nochmal probieren bald.
Wir sind sogar nicht nur in der Pause gegangen, wir sind während der Vorstellung aufgestanden und rausgegangen. So war das.
Aber ohne Türen schlagen.
Ja, wir haben nur kurz gezeigt, dass wir gehen. Ilja Sudskäfer ist euch ein Begriff. Wir haben ihn breit diskutiert, als JetGPT vorgestellt wurde. Denn er war ja der Forschungsleiter bei OpenAI. Dann gab es diesen Turmult. Sam Altman wurde entlassen und kam wieder zurück. Sudskäfer hat geschrieben, das ist der größte Tag meines Lebens, wir sind wieder ein Team. Und jetzt stellte er sich raus, dass er ein Team sein wollte, aber es ging. Jetzt hat er geschrieben, ich möchte eine neue Company gründen, sie heißt SSI, also Super Intelligence. Und er möchte die besonders safe machen. Safe Super Intelligence, SSI. Twitter-Antwort darauf. Please teach it to laugh. Also die Leute haben ein klares, sie wissen was sie wollen, nämlich sowas.
Alles steht Kopf Teil 3.
Alles steht Kopf. Das ist noch Teil 1, aber du hast Teil 2 gesehen.
Ich hab Teil 2 über mich ergehen lassen.
Und ich dachte mir, wenn die Gefühle doch so im Mittelpunkt stehen, und wir gleichzeitig so gefühlsmittellos in dieser Welt nicht mehr einen noch aus, nur noch ist jetzt Geld Zeit oder Zeit Geld, und wo ist denn da das Gefühl? Wir hören uns, ich würde sagen, zwei Clips noch an. Bevor wir das Thema dann nächste Woche, wir sehen uns ja zum Ende des Monats vertiefen. Und zwar hören wir Mark Zuckerberg. Wir kennen ihn als, klar, Facebook-Gründer und so, und ein großer Verfechter des Metaverse. Und wir wissen heute, Metaverse ist auf jeden Fall die falsche Richtung, in die man abgebogen ist. Man muss ja irgendwas mit KI machen. Später kann man das wieder verheiraten, aber jetzt ist erstmal der Drops gelutscht. Jetzt wird die ganze Power in KI investiert. Und Mark Zuckerberg nennt...
Der tut das ja durchaus sinnvoll, ne? Also es ist ja doch ganz erstaunlich, dass er das auch eigentlich als Open Source dann anlegt. Also das heißt, wir haben schon... Wir müssen jetzt die Debatte nicht aufnehmen, aber ich glaube schon, dass Zuckerberg offenbar jetzt gerade sehr gut versteht, dass diese Rivalitäten, die jetzt gerade stattfinden, zwischen den anderen KI-Produzenten, ChatGPT-Herstellern, dass er die im Prinzip ausspielen kann, in dem er so stark investiert, aber nicht diese geschlossenen Pay-Systeme daraus macht und damit eigentlich denen ja das Wasser abgräbt.
Wir werden das ausführlich diskutieren, da gibt es ganz viel zu sagen, aber Fakt ist, ChatGPT kann man Nachrichten schicken und dann kriegt man Antworten, Claude auch. Bei Facebook kann man das Modell einfach auf sein eigenes Computer runterladen, hat keine Internetverbindung am Laufen, niemand weiß, was man gerade mit dem Modell klärt, sondern man kriegt seine Antworten lokal. Darin liegen Business-Vorteile für Facebook, die jetzt nicht so gemeinwohlstützend sind, wie wir es hier auf die Kürze leider nur kurz sagen können. Aber wir hören hier mal Max Zuckerberg zum Thema. Metaverse ist nicht mehr das große Thema, ich weiß. Ich werbe aber gleichzeitig damit, also Max Zuckerberg, dass er 400.000 von diesen komischen Grafikkarten hat, auf denen das da alles gerechnet wird, also der weltgrößte Eigner von diesen neuen Nvidia-Chips. Und er flackt hier mal das Thema aus, was ihn am meisten interessiert.
Ich bin sehr konzentriert auf eine Modelle, die ich noch nie gesehen habe, wie viele andere Menschen in der Industrie so konzentriert sind auf das. So viel der menschliche Geist ist nur für die Verständnis von Menschen und die Verständnis deiner Erkennung und Emotionen. Man kann sagen, dass es vielleicht nur Video oder Image ist, aber es ist auch eine sehr spezialisierte Version. Es gibt also alle verschiedenen Möglichkeiten, die man auf die Modelle trainieren will, und die auch viel besser im Reisen und im Erinnern. Ich glaube nicht, dass wir uns in der Zukunft in einen Query-Kontext-Window in die Erkennung von komplexen Fragen bewegen.
Er möchte emotionale Intelligenz irgendwie reinprogrammieren, um das Verständnis zu verschärfen. Das könnt ihr euch alle so ungefähr vorstellen. Diesen Podcast hier gibt es auch als Transkript, wenn man ihn nachliest und die Aufgabe bekommt, markier mal die Stellen, wo du glaubst, das Publikum hätte gelacht. Trefferquote ist nahezu null. Also man kann so ein bisschen, weil man uns schon mal gehört hat, so erahnen, aber eigentlich liegt man immer daneben. Manchmal hat man so Interviews, die hört man und versteht sie sofort. Und dann liest man aber diesen automatisierter, generierten Text mit, der wortwörtlich genau das abbildet, was da gesagt wird, und man versteht nichts davon. Also nicht nur versteht man nicht, was da witzig ist oder so, sondern man versteht auch inhaltlich gar nicht, was da passiert. Also irgendwo ist so eine Verständnisebene abseits der Worte. Und die erste Frage, die man dem Maschine so gestellt hat, ist, finde doch mal raus in einer Sprache, die du nicht verstehst und du hörst zu, versuche zu prognostizieren, wann jemand aufhört zu reden, sodass der andere dran ist. Solche Sachen, das verarbeiten wir nicht auf der inhaltlichen. Klar, man wird dem Maschine immer sagen, du hast deinen Punkt gemacht und dann warst du fertig, ist doch logisch und so. Nee, so läuft es ja nicht. Das wissen wir alle aus unseren Zoom-Konferenzen, als plötzlich diese kleinen Delays reinkamen und wir dachten, ach so, ich dachte, du bist fertig, aber du redest ja noch weiter und so weiter. Da geht dann schon alles durcheinander. Jetzt hab ich euch ja eben gefragt, nach zwei Dimensionen war schon alles drunter und drüber. Ist mir zu warm, aber finde ich den Content irgendwie gut. Also habe ich so ein körperliches Gefühl, aber fühle mich irgendwie intellektueller angesprochen. Totales Mismatching. Jetzt hat man sich hier gedacht, okay, wir haben ja keine wissenschaftliche Grundlage. Wir können irgendwie die Psycho-Bücher lesen. Und dann steht da so, ja, Menschen können. Und dann eben der Disney-Film, wütend, erregt, lustig, also angeheitert oder zornig sein. Und dann war es das schon. Jetzt hört mal genau zu, der Clip ist sehr schwer zu hören, aber wir versuchen es. Wir hören im letzten Clip den CEO von Hume AI zu, Alan Cohen, der beim Big Technology Podcast zu Gast ist, der jetzt mal die Zahl der Dimensionen nennt, die die Maschine selbstständig als Muster oder wie auch immer herausgelesen hat, wenn Menschen reden, nach wie vielen Dimensionen man emotional etwas vororten muss, um dann erfolgreich anschlussfähig zu sein. Das ist extrem genau. Ja, also bisher kommt OpenAI und sagt, wir machen jetzt Whisper-AI, wir transkribieren alles, was mündlich vorliegt, und dann haben wir Datengrundlage, um unsere Dings zu trainieren. Also, Stefan hat gerade Flasche gesagt, also transkribiere ich jetzt Flasche, und dann sagen die, ja, wir können aber dann an das Wort Flasche, wie er es gesagt hat, noch 600 Dimensionen der emotionalen Verortung dranhängen, und wenn wir das Bild dazu haben, auch noch mal hunderte Mimik-Ausdrücke. Also auf der Ebene macht Max Hagerberg hier gerade Forschung.
Das heißt, sehr viel Rechenleistung ist da erforderlich, um das dann herauszukristallisieren. Es gibt noch einen anderen Weg, den habe ich festgestellt. Heute im Hotelzimmer. Ich bin nicht raus, weil ich Angst vor den Fußballfans hatte. Und habe also den ganzen Tag das getan, was man dann so tut. Man sieht sich eine Serie an. Und zwar habe ich mir Maxton Hall, die Erfolgsserre auf Amazon Prime angesehen. Werde ich auch noch besprechen. Aber die These kann ich schon mal hier vorwegnehmen. Jetzt in Verbindung mit KI. Momentan hat die KI also auf so vielen Ebenen zu arbeiten, um diese ganz verschiedenen Ausdrucksmöglichkeiten die der Mensch so hat, zu erkennen. Und der Reduktionismus, den wir bei Alles steht Kopf 2 erleben, dass es dann doch sehr simpel gestrickt ist, die menschliche Psyche. Das ist etwas, was wir natürlich in dieser klischierten Populärkultur, wie diese Tele-Novelas oder auch solche Serien, die auf Schnulz-Romanen bestehen, sehr gut sehen können. Nämlich alles, was man dort sieht, sind so passkonforme, standardisierte, fast würde ich sagen, fordistisch produzierte, serielle Gefühle, dass die KI damit überhaupt gar kein Problem hätte, genau zu erkennen, wann ist da gerade einer wütend, traurig, lustig oder sonst was. Und in gewisser Weise, das wäre jetzt meine Verschwörungstheorie, ist das also eine Auftragsarbeit von den KI-Zentren, denn das eine ist, die Rechenleistung immer weiter zu erhöhen, um dann irgendwann unsere 1000 verschiedenen Ausdrücke doch wahrzunehmen und lesen zu können. Die andere Möglichkeit ist, dass man den Leuten so lange Serien verabreicht, in denen auch irgendwann ihre Ausdrucksbandbreite zusammenschrumpft auf etwa sieben verschiedene Gesichtsausdrücke. Und Sie wissen, Pils Schweiger hat es mit anderthalb versucht. Das ist also auch eine Möglichkeit der KI-Arbeit abzunehmen, in dem wir immer reduktionistischer sind. Wir haben das schon sehr mal deutlich gemacht, als wir so über Überwachung gesprochen haben, so am Anfang der Neuen Zwanziger und alles. Vielleicht ist auch noch mal die kalte Person, also sich nicht in die Karten blicken lassen, auch noch mal eine Möglichkeit in gewisser Weise, sich zu verschließen vor der KI, vor diesem Blick. Also der liebe Gott sieht alles, aber die KI kann nur immer das sehen, was sie sieht. Aber vielleicht gibt es dann bald die neue dezente Form des Ausdrucks, dass man nicht mehr so leicht lesbar wird. Oder wie Karl Lagerfeld, als er mal eingeladen wurde auf so einer Gala in Düsseldorf, und der bekam dann immer Privatstatt plus eine Million Euro. Ich denke, dafür kann man es machen. Jedenfalls kam er dort an und die Reporterin fragte ihn, was sind heute ihre Gefühle hier in Düsseldorf? Und der sagte, muss ich jetzt auch noch Gefühle haben?
Also daran schließen wir nächste Woche dann an und entlassen uns heute operngerecht 22 Uhr aus der Laden vorbei, denn die alten Leute müssen ins Bett. Nein, gilt für uns natürlich nicht. Vertagen wir uns auf nächste Woche.
Machen wir. Schönen Abend noch, vielen Dank.